ओके
आई थिंक आई एम लाइव राइट ओके चलिए सो लाइव
आ चुका हूं मैं मुझे एक बार कंफर्म कर दो
आप सभी जल्दी से चैट में कंफर्म कर दीजिए
इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली प्लीज
कंफर्म इन द चैट जल्दी से फटाफट फटाफट
कंफर्म कीजिए गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग एक
बंदा बोल रहा है गुलगुल इवनिंग यह क्या
होता है भाई गुलूगुल इवनिंग क्या होता है
यार गुलगुल इवनिंग सही है
इतने कलाकार कैसे हो जाते हो तुम लोग यार
गुलूग्लू इवनिंग वाले
कमाल है
गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते
नमस्ते
गुड इवनिंग की जगह नमस्ते बोला करो यार
नमस्ते ज्यादा अच्छा लगता है अपना
अपनापन टाइप लगता है मुझे
ओके
नमस्ते डिफ्रॉनिकस्टर्स नमस्ते।
मैं बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया। एकदम बढ़िया
हूं मैं। आई होप आप सब भी अच्छे होंगे।
मजे में होंगे, बिंदास होंगे।
बढ़िया कर रहे होंगे लाइफ में अपने एंड
हेल्दी भी होंगे। सबसे जरूरी है हेल्दी
होना। क्योंकि बिना हेल्दी हुए आप कुछ भी
नहीं कर सकते ना। सो हेल्दी होना इज़
वेरीेंट। राइट? चलिए। सो सबसे पहले अ
वेलकम टू द 10थ क्लास ऑफ दिस एसओसी अ जॉब
रेडी एसओसी एल1 फ्री बट विद क्वालिटी
ट्रेनिंग बाय डिफ्रॉनिक्स एंड देखतेदेखते
हमारे 10 क्लास जो है वो आज पूरे हो जा
रहे हैं।
टुडे इज़ आवर एथ 10थ क्लास एंड एक्सट्रीमली
ये काफी प्राउड की बात है कि अ हमने शुरू
किया था जीरो से हमने बिल्कुल ही अ
स्क्रैच से स्टार्ट किया एंड आज वी हैव वी
आर अ
टू द 10थ क्लास ऑफ दिस सेशन एंड काफी
फ्रीक्वेंट हुई हैं। बीच में थोड़ा गैप
आया था। आपकी वजह से आया था। मेरी वजह से
बिल्कुल नहीं आया था। जब आपने कमेंट्स
नहीं करे थे 200। सो आप सबको जैसे कि पता
है मैं एक बार छोटा सा रीकैप मार देता हूं
आप सबके लिए। ठीक है? सभी रेडी हो जाइए।
सबको पता है कि सबसे पहले आपको तो इस
वीडियो से और इस चैनल से अगर आपने कुछ भी
सीखा है या सीखते हो या अगर आपको चैनल पे
आके ऐसा लगता है कि यू आर गेटिंग समथिंग
ट्रूली इंफॉर्मेशनेशनल एंड दैट कुड शेप
योर फ्यूचर और करियर एंड एसओसी ट्रेनिंग
से भी आपको कुछ सीखने को मिलता है तो आप
इस चैनल पे अगर सब्सक्राइब नहीं होंगे तो
सब्सक्राइब तो कर ही दीजिएगा एक लाइक ठोक
दीजिएगा एंड हमारा हर सेशन नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट सेशन जो आएगा वो किस पे डिपेंड
करता है? आपके 200 कमेंट्स पे। पहले टू
250 कमेंट्स का टारगेट मैं आपको दे रहा था
बट अब मैंने 200 उसको कर दिया है क्योंकि
250 शायद आप नहीं कर पाएंगे। तो 200
कमेंट्स आपने किया और नेक्स्ट क्लास आपके
लिए हाजिर हो जाएंगी। चाहे आपने एक दिन
में कर दिया नेक्स्ट डे आपकी क्लास आ
जाएगी। आपने दो दिन में कर दिया नेक्स्ट
डे आपकी क्लास आ जाएगी। ये सब आपके ऊपर
में डिपेंड करता है। ठीक है? ये टोटली
टोटली इट्स टोटली अप टू यू। तो आई होप कि
आप इसको समझेंगे अच्छे से। ठीक है? दूसरी
चीजें शेयर करेंगे उन दोस्तों के बीच अ इस
वीडियोस इन वीडियोस को जो एसओसी के लिए
काफी एंथोजियास्टिक है। एसओसी सीखना चाहते
हैं। एसओसी एल1 बनना चाहते हैं। एक जॉब
रेडी ट्रेनिंग फ्री में करना चाहते हैं
बिना कोई पैसा दिए उनके साथ जरूर शेयर
कीजिएगा हर सोशल मीडिया प्रोफाइल्स पे।
एंड साथ ही में जब भी आप किसी भी लाइव
सेक्शन में हमारे चैनल पे आके किसी भी
एसओसी की क्लास को जब ओपन करेंगे आप एंड
इसके डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाएंगे तो आपको दो
लिंक मिलेगी। एक एसओसी का स्पेसिफिक एक
स्पेशल WhatsApp ग्रुप मिलेगा। इसको जरूर
जॉइ कर लीजिएगा। एसओसी से रिलेटेड जितने
रिसोर्सेज हैं, नोट्स हैं, गिव अवे की
अनाउंसमेंट अभी होने वाली है। जहां पे
आपको वाउचर्स मिल सकते हैं। ट्राईकमी,
Zomato या किसी भी जो भी आप वाउचर चाहते
हैं, वो मिलेंगे। वो सब आपको इसी पे इनेशन
मिलेगी। एंड अपकमिंग जो सर्टिफिकेशन हो
गाइस कंप्लीट होने के बाद ट्रेनिंग के
उसकी भी आपको डिटेल्स वहीं मिलेंगी। एंड
दूसरा जो आपको
[हंसी] दूसरा जो आपको लिंक मिलेगा यह
हमारे WhatsApp चैनल का मिलेगा
डेफ्रोनिक्स एकडमी जो कि बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट टू फॉलो है। यहां आके आप सारी
डिटेल्स सबसे पहले जो भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
ओवरऑल इनफेशन होती है आपको सबसे पहले मिल
जाती है। तो इसको जरूर फॉलो की लीजिएगा।
11,000 से भी ज्यादा डेफ्रोनिक स्टर्स
यहां हमारे साथ जुड़े हुए हैं इस चैनल पे।
ये हो गया। और यहां Lindin पे आप मुझे
फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मुझसे कनेक्ट हो सकते
हैं Lindin पे। अगर आप चाहते हैं मुझसे
कनेक्ट होना तो बिल्कुल आप आइए। यू आर मोर
देन वेलकम lindin.com
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर आप इस पे आएंगे एंड
यहां पे आप मुझसे कनेक्ट करके फॉलो कर
सकते हैं। एंड डिफरेंट काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग्स
मुझसे जो भी चीजें डिस्कस करना चाहते हैं
कुछ वो कर सकते हैं आप। देन यहीं पे
Lindin पे ही आप सिंपल डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च
करेंगे। एंड यू विल गेट द डिफ्रॉनिक्सic
साइबर सिक्योरिटी lindin पेज जहां पे आप
डिफ्रॉनिक्स हमारी कंपनी हमारे स्टार्टअप
के साथ जुड़ के और इसकी जो जर्नी है उसको
फॉलो कर सकते हैं। एंड जो भी अनाउंसमेंट्स
एंड डिटेल्स वगैरह हम कंपनी से के
रिगार्डिंग या कोर्सेज वगैरह ये सब
डालेंगे तो आपको यहां पे वो चीजें अपडेट
सबसे पहले मिलेगी। यहां पे 21,000 लगभग
लोग हमसे जुड़े हैं। साथ ही यह हमारा एक्स
का पेज है डिफ़्रोनिक्स का x.com dfonic
accडमी। आप इस पे फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यहां
पे आपको टाइम टू टाइम इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें
जो है देखने को स्टफ्स जो है मिल जाएगी।
यह हमारा Lindin पेज है। यह हमारा
Instagram पेज है डिफ़ॉनस Academy जहां पे
लगभग 500 लोग हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। यहां पे
आप इनेशनल कंटेंट्स, रील्स एंड ऑल इन सब
के लिए आप जुड़ सकते हैं। ये हमारी
वेबसाइट है। इसको आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं। एकडमी पे जाके हमारी कोर्सर्सेस को
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। जो हम कोर्सर्सेस
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट कोर्सर्सेस प्रोवाइड करते
हैं। एंड साथ ही इस नंबर पे कांटेक्ट करके
आप हमसे अपनी क्वेरीज या कोई भी क्वेश्चन
कुछ भी आपको वो पूछ सकते हैं। चलिए ये सब
तो कहानियां हो गई। ये सारी चीजें डिस्कस
हो गई। अब आते हैं हमारे मेन मुद्दे पे।
मेन मुद्दा क्या है? मैं आपसे पहले वो
डिस्कस करना चाहता हूं। देखो एसओसी की
क्लासेस ये 10वीं क्लासेस हैं। एंड मैं
मान के चलता हूं कि 10थ 10 क्लासेस अगर
आपने ये 10वीं 10 के 10 क्लासेस को
प्रॉपर्ली फॉलो किया होगा। तो आपने बहुत
कुछ अभी तक एसओसी एल1 बनने के लिए कंप्लीट
पूरा कर लिया होगा। ठीक है? अब मैं आपको
यहां पे कुछ चीजें बताना चाहता हूं। आज जो
हम टॉपिक अह जो है वह करने वाले हैं, वह
काफी इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक होने वाला है। एंड
आई होप कि आप इसको भी उसी तरीके से डील
करेंगे जैसे बाकी टॉपिक्स को आपने किया है
अभी तक। एंड एक-एक चीज बहुत ज्यादा बहुत
ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है आपके लिए। एक-एक चीज
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। तो आपको कोई
भी चीज को स्किप नहीं करना है कि अरे भाई
चलो इसको छोड़ देते हैं। इसको रहने देते
हैं। अरे ये तो वैसे हो जाएगा, वैसे हो
जाएगा। नहीं करना है। बिल्कुल भी नहीं
करना है। यू हैव टू गो थ्रू ऑल द टॉपिक्स।
क्योंकि आप ये जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग ले रहे
हो। आप कोई ऐसे ही मतलब एरागरा ट्रेनिंग
आप नहीं ले रहे हो कि कहीं से कुछ भी पढ़ा
दिया किसी ने कहीं से कुछ भी आपने पढ़
लिया और हो गया काम खत्म नहीं यू हैव टू
गो थ्रू स्टेप एंड स्टेप वाइज जब आप आगे
बढ़ेंगे तो एक-एक टॉपिक जितना इंपॉर्टेंट
है उतना मैं आपको बताऊंगा एल वन लेवल के
लिए जो चीजें इंपॉर्टेंट है वो सब
बताऊंगा। ठीक है? अब मैं अगर आपको यहां पे
अ विजिट करूं इफ आई गो एंड ओपन द ट्राई
हैक मी। ठीक है? तो मैंने आपको फिशिंग
पढ़ाया। ठीक है? अब मैंने आपको फिशिंग
पढ़ाया था। आई टॉट यू फिशिंग। राइट? अब
देखो, अब फिशिंग जब मैंने कराया था, तो
उसमें एक यहां पे ट्राईकमी में फिशिंग का
सेमुलेशन भी आपको मिलेगा। मैं यहां पे पाथ
पे चलता हूं।
मैं यहां पे पाथ पे चलता हूं। अब यहां पे
पाथ पे जब आप आएंगे तो यहां पे एक
सेमुलेशन मिलेगा इंट्रोडक्शन टू फिशिंग
का। जब मैं इस इंट्रोडक्शन टू फिशिंग में
जाऊंगा।
ठीक है? एंड यहां पर जब मैं यह सेमुलेशन
मान लो आपको कराने कराऊं मैं आपको जो कि
मैंने अभी नहीं कराया है। एंड मैं थोड़े
डिफरेंट टाइप से कोशिश करूंगा उसको टैकल
करने का।
मैं जैसे ही यहां पे स्टार्ट पे क्लिक
करता हूं यहां पे आपसे पूछा जाता है कि आप
अपना एसआईएम टूल जो है उसको चूज़ कीजिए। अब
देखो मैं क्यों एक-एक चीज लेकर चल रहा हूं
इसका रीज़न अभी आपको समझ में आ जाएगा। यहां
पर स्प्लंक दिया हुआ है, इलास्टिक दिया
हुआ है। एंड यहां पर सेंटिनल दिया हुआ है।
इनमें से तीनों में से एज अ बिगिनर मैं
मान के चलता हूं आपको कुछ भी नहीं पता है।
कोई सा भी टूल आपको यूज़ करने नहीं आता।
प्रॉपर्ली आप यू डोंट नो हाउ टू यूज़ दिस
टूल्स। जब आप ये टूल्स जानते ही नहीं है,
कैसे वर्क करता है? ये टूल्स कैसे ऑपरेट
करते हैं? क्या-क्या ऑप्शंस होते हैं? किस
तरीके से हम क्वेरीज़ पास करते हैं इन
टूल्स के अंदर में अलग-अलग अपने रिजल्ट्स
के लिए। तो आप फिर कैसे इस पर्टिकुलर
सेमुलेशन को कर लेंगे फिशिंग की ओनली
नॉलेज से? तो हर कांसेप्ट जो है ना हज हर
कांसेप्ट वो बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है।
हर कांसेप्ट बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है जो
आपको करना है। एंड तभी आप ऐसे लैब्स को और
ऐसे सेमुलेशंस को जो है सॉल्व कर पाएंगे
या फिर उसको समझ पाएंगे। अब कहीं से कुछ
देख के आपने ये सॉल्व कर दिया तो वो तो
कोई भी कर देगा। आपके बहुत छोटी सी बात है
वो। बट आपका कंसेप्ट क्लियर नहीं हो
पाएगा। लेकिन कांसेप्ट के बिना कुछ भी
पॉसिबल नहीं। हर एक चीज़ कांसेप्ट से
इनिशिएट होती है एंड वो एक्सट्रीम लेवल तक
जाती है एंड तब जो है आप सक्सेसफुल हो
जाते हैं जब आप कॉनंसेप्ट्स को फॉलो करते
हैं। यहां पे मैं जो आज टॉपिक लेकर आया
हूं आपके लिए एक और अ इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक
है जो कि साइबर सिक्योरिटी फॉर एसओसी मॉडल
मॉड्यूल में हम लेके चल रहे हैं। जहां पे
हम बात करने वाले हैं लैटरल मूवमेंट के
बारे में। लैटरल मूवमेंट एंड प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशंस ये दो चीजों को हम देखेंगे। अब
देखो लैटरल मूवमेंट, प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
दीज़ आर द पार्ट्स ऑफ साइबर सिक्योरिटी
जहां पे आप इन डेप्थ बहुत कुछ पढ़ते हैं।
एसओसी के लिए आपको बहुत डीप जाके पढ़ने की
जरूरत नहीं है। एटलीस्ट नॉट फॉर L1 L2 के
लिए फिर आपको डीप घुसना पड़ता है थोड़ा। L2
के लिए फिर आपको अंदर जाना पड़ता है। एंड
उन्हीं चीजों को और ज्यादा एक्सप्लोर करना
होता है। तो जब आप L1 के लिए प्रिपेयर कर
रहे हैं, यू नीड अ बेस एंड वो बेस जब आपका
स्ट्रांग हो जाएगा, जब बेस आपका क्लियर हो
जाएगा, आप एलएन के लिए बिल्कुल रेडी हो
जाएंगे। किसी भी कंपनी के इंटरव्यूज के
लिए आप रेडी हो जाएंगे। यू कैन गो एंड गेट
इंटरव्यूड। ठीक है? ये मैं आपको गारंटी
देता हूं।
आएगा लॉग एनालिसिस का भी।
लॉग एनालिसिस का तो डिटेल वीडियो आएगा
क्योंकि लॉग एनालिसिस इज़ द वन ऑफ़ द
मोस्टेंट पार्ट ऑफ एसओसी एल1 जर्नी। राइट?
कोई बात नहीं। निशा चौधरी इट्स ओके। आज
प्रैक्टिकल होगा क्या? नहीं प्रैक्टिकल जब
आएगा तो आपको बता दिया जाएगा। जब भी
प्रैक्टिकल होगा आपको बताया जाएगा। आप
टेंशन मत लो। प्रैक्टिकल से मैं आपको
गारंटी बोल रहा हूं ना जब आप जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग कर रहे हो तो यह मत सोचो कि
प्रैक्टिकल कब आएगा। बल्कि ये सोचो कि जो
भी आ रहा है वो सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट है।
प्रैक्टिकल भी इंपॉर्टेंट है उतना ही
जितना ये थ्योरी आपका और कांसेप्ट्स
इंपॉर्टेंट है। ये दिमाग में आपको डालना
पड़ेगा। ठीक है?
क्रिटिकल केसेस के बारे में अभी कैसे
बताऊं? जब आप लोग तैयार ही नहीं हो
क्रिटिकल केसेस के लिए। कुछ लोग हो सकता
है पहले से जानते होंगे थोड़ा बहुत वो
तैयार भी होंगे। बट मेरा फोकस मैंने पहले
ही बताया कि बिगिनर्स हैं, न्यू कमर्स हैं
एंड जो इसमें आना चाहते हैं वो है। मेरा
फोकस वो बिल्कुल भी नहीं है जो ऑलरेडी
एसओसी में है और ऑलरेडी एसओसी के बारे में
जानकारी रखते हैं। बिकॉज़ फिर क्या फायदा
हुआ इस ट्रेनिंग का? फ्री ट्रेनिंग देने
का क्या फायदा हुआ? राइट? तो प्लीज बियर
विद दैट। ओके?
कोई बात नहीं।
कितने दिन में पूरा कोर्स खत्म हो जाएगा?
मैंने बोला ही था आपको। पहले ही बोल दिया
था स्टार्टिंग में। थ्री टू फोर मंथ्स का
टाइम लग जाएगा कंप्लीट कोर्स को कवर करने
में आपका एसओसी एल1 के लिए कंप्लीट कवर
मैं कर दूंगा एंड उसके बाद आपका इंटरव्यू
सेशन कुछ एक दो सेशंस चलेंगे मॉक
इंटरव्यूज और इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन भी मैं
कराऊंगा इस ट्रेनिंग को खत्म करने के बाद
तो आपको ना किसी चीज की चिंता नहीं करनी
आप बस एलिजिबिलिटी देख लीजिए आप अपना मैं
बस इतना ही बोलूंगा अब मेरी कंपनी है मैं
बोलूंगा कि मेरे को देखो बात ये है मैं
उसमें कुछ नहीं कर सकता ना आप कर सकते हो
एलिजिबिलिटी के केस में अगर मान लो मेरी
कंपनी है और मैं बोलूं कि मेरे को सिर्फ
12th पास ही बंदा चाहिए जॉब के लिए। अगर
बीटेक या ग्रेजुएशन करा है तो वो मैं नहीं
लूंगा। तो वो तो मेरी चॉइस है ना। राइट?
उसमें कैंडिडेट क्या कर सकता है बेचारा?
वो तो फिर देखेगा ना कि 12th पास कौन
कैंडिडेट है? वही आके अप्लाई करेगा।
सिमिलर हैपेंस इफ यू गो टू कंपनी टू
अप्लाई एंड ऑल। उनका एक रिक्वायरमेंट होता
है। वो रिक्वायरमेंट अगर आप फुलफिल कर
चुके हैं तो आप एसओसी के इंटरव्यू में
अपने आप को छोटा नहीं महसूस करेंगे। अपने
आपको अ स्किल लेस नहीं आप अपने आपको फील
करेंगे। आप समझेंगे कि वी यू नो एवरीथिंग।
अगर आपने प्रॉपर्ली इसको अटेंड करा है
क्लासेस को, प्रॉपर्ली नोट्स बनाया है,
प्रॉपर्ली सिंसियरली फॉलो करा है तब। ठीक
है? बस
या
सर इतना लेट मत कीजिए क्लास लेने में।
देखो मैंने पहले ही बोला है क्लास लेना
लेट मेरे हाथ में नहीं है यार मैं आपको
पहले ही बोल चुका हूं 200 प्लस कमेंट्स आप
एक दिन में कर दीजिए यूनिक कमेंट्स होने
नहीं कि एक ही बंदा 10 कमेंट कर रहा है तो
वो तो वैलिड वैसे भी नहीं मानता मैं बट
अगर यूनिक कमेंट्स आपने 200 प्लस कर दिए
आपने एक दिन में जैसे आज क्लास हुई आपने
कल यूनिक कमेंट्स कर दिया परसों मैं क्लास
लेकर आ जाऊंगा वो तो आपके हाथों में मैंने
पहले ही बोल दिया कि एवरीथिंग इज इन योर
हैंड्स। चलिए
ओके सो लेट्स स्टार्ट। सबसे पहले हम बात
करते हैं लैटरल मूवमेंट। यह सारे जो
टॉपिक्स हैं इतने इंपॉर्टेंट है जितना आप
सोच भी नहीं सकते हैं। इसकी सिंसियरनेस को
समझिए और अपने अंदर एक सिंसियरनेस लेकर
आइए क्योंकि यही टॉपिक्स कल को अगर मैं यह
वीडियोस प्राइवेट कर दूं या मेंबर ओनली कर
दूं या पेड कर दूं तो मैं लिटरली बोल रहा
हूं आप पैसे देके देखेंगे। आप पैसे देके
ही चाहे यह कोर्स कहीं और से आप पैसे देके
करेंगे। और यही चीज़ मैं फ्री में करा रहा
हूं तो कई लोगों को यह चीज़ समझ नहीं आती
है। बताओ पता है मेरे पास एक बंदे का कॉल
आया। हालांकि मुझसे बात करना चाहता था वह
तो हमारे ऑफिशियल नंबर पे उसका एक मैसेज
आया था कि मुझे बात करना है नीesर से तो
ठीक है मेरे को पता चला तो मैंने बोला ठीक
है बात करते हैं मैंने उससे बात करी बंदा
सब कुछ बहुत गाइडेंस वगैरह कुछ मांग रहा
था मैंने उसको गाइड किया उसके बाद लास्ट
में बोलता है कि सर हम आपके पास कोई एसओसी
की कोई कोर्स है क्या पेड कोर्स मैंने
बोला कि हां पेड कोर्स है YouTube पे है
तुम वहां पे देख सकते हो उसको नहीं पता था
इसके बारे में तो बोलता है नहीं नहीं सर
YouTube पे नहीं मुझे पेड कोर्स अगर कोई
आपका है कोर्स जो चलाते हो आप जिसमें कि
आप या कोई ट्रेनर पढ़ाता हो अच्छे से
क्योंकि डिफ्रॉनिक्स बहुत अच्छा मुझे पता
है बहुत अच्छा कंटेंट देती है तो मुझे
लगता है कि ये पेड कोर्स बहुत अच्छा हो
मैंने बोला कि हां जी पेड कोर्स ही है बट
मैं उसके कोई चार्ज नहीं लूंगा आपसे फिर
YouTube पे पड़ी है प्लेलिस्ट के अंदर में
एकदम फ्री है तो खैर अरे सर नहीं सर मैं
वो फ्री वाली नहीं खोज रहा था मुझे कुछ
थोड़ा सा अच्छा कंटेंट चाहिए था इस वजह से
मैंने सोचा कि पेड कोर्स पूछूं मैंने तो
फिर मैंने उसको समझाया कि भैया मैं जब
बार-बार बोल बोल रहा हूं कि पेड कोर्स है
YouTube पे फ्री में पड़ी हुई है। तो देखो
माइंडसेट कितना कितना ज्यादा अजीब है
लोगों का। मतलब सोचो ऐसे एक स्टूडेंट नहीं
है। बहुत सारे ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स हैं जिनका
माइंडसेट सेम सिमिलर लेवल पे है। तो मैं
अब क्या करूं इस केस में? मैं बता ही तो
सकता हूं। बोल सकता हूं। तो मैंने बोला
भाई वो पेड कोर्स ही है। कल को मैं उसको
पेड कर दूंगा। तुम आके बोलोगे कि मुझे
खरीदना है। अभी फ्री में मिल रही है तो
तुम्हें कोई कदर नहीं है। तुम्हें लग रहा
है कि फ्री की चीज़ है। दैट्स द मेन थिंग।
राइट? तो प्लीज इसको थोड़ा सा वैल्यू
दीजिए। चलिए लेटरल मूवमेंट पे हम आते हैं।
एकदम इसके साथ जुड़ जाइए। मेरे साथ जुड़
जाइए। जब आप कोई टॉपिक पढ़ा पढ़ रहे हैं
और जब मैं पढ़ा रहा हूं तो यू गेट
कनेक्टेड विद मी एंड मैं इस टॉपिक के साथ
तो हम एक दूसरे के साथ कनेक्ट हो जाते
हैं। देखो लैटरल मूवमेंट इज व्हेन एन
अटैकर मूव्स फ्रॉम वन कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम
टू अनदर सिस्टम इन द नेटवर्क। एक नेटवर्क
के अंदर एक अटैकर घुसता है। वो एक सिस्टम
से दूसरे सिस्टम में ट्रैवल कर रहा होता
है। यानी एक सिस्टम को उसने कॉम्प्रोमाइज
किया। अब उसी की हेल्प से वो दूसरे सिस्टम
के अंदर में भी घुस जा रहा है। दिस इज
कॉल्ड लैटरल मूवमेंट। एक सिस्टम से दूसरे
सिस्टम के अंदर में लैटरल मूवमेंट यही
होता है।
2000 लोग वीडियो देखते हैं। 200 लोग कमेंट
कर दिया करो दोस्त। क्लासेस जल्दी आएंगी।
हां, बिल्कुल सही बोला।
हां, एनवायरमेंट ही ऐसा है। बिल्कुल सही
बोला। क्या बोल सकते हैं अब? तो एक सिस्टम
से दूसरे सिस्टम में घुस जाते हैं। वो
लैटरल मूवमेंट कहलाता है। इंस्टेड ऑफ
लिविंग द नेटवर्क द टैकर मूव्स साइडवेज
अक्रॉस मशीन मशीनंस। ठीक है?
मेरे को कॉफी पीनी पर पड़ती है कई बार
क्लास के पहले या ड्यूरिंग द क्लास
कभी-कभी पी लेता हूं। अदरवाइज मैं जनरली
क्लास क्योंकि मेरे को नींद आती है कई बार
जब थोड़ा सा इधर-उधर का है सो नहीं पाता
हूं मैं कई बार तो नींद कम हुई होती है तो
मेरे को नींद आने लगती है फिर भी मैं
क्लासेस तो ले रहा हूं आपकी अगर मेरे को
200 कमेंट्स मिल गए हैं तो मैं क्लासेस तो
ले रहा हूं तो मैं बहाने नहीं कर रहा आप
क्यों बहाने करते हो यार मेरे को समझ नहीं
आता ये तो अब देखो साइडवेज अटैकर क्या
करता है ना कि एक नेटवर्क के अंदर घुस गया
कैसे भी करके मतलब अलग-अलग तरीके हैं घुस
गया वो हैकिंग का फेजेस हैकिंग के अलग-अलग
फेजेस को कवर करके। अब वो क्या करेगा? एक
सिस्टम में घुसा। अब एक सिस्टम से दूसरे
सिस्टम में, दूसरे सिस्टम से तीसरे सिस्टम
में। ये इसी तरीके से घूमता रहेगा। इसको
हम लैटरल मूवमेंट कहते हैं। अटैकर्स डू
दिस टू क्यों करते हैं ऐसा? वैल्यूुएबल
डेटा को फाइंड करने के लिए। डोमेन
कंट्रोलर तक पहुंचने के लिए। डोमेन
कंट्रोलर वो होते हैं जहां पे सारे
कंप्यूटरटर्स का कंट्रोल होता है। एक तरह
से अभी आप मान लीजिए दिस इज़ डोमेन
कंट्रोलर्स वगैरह जो है आप एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरीज में इसको पढ़ेंगे। एक तरह से
समझिए कि एक पूरा डोमेन जो है उसके
कंट्रोल में रहता है। एक डोमेन के अंदर
बहुत सारे कंप्यूटरटर्स हो सकते हैं ऑपरेट
कर सकते हैं। पॉसिबल है। तो उसको कंट्रोल
ही ये करता है। एक ऑपरेट करता है। एक्सेस
एडमिन अकाउंट्स। एडमिन अकाउंट्स को एक्सेस
करना क्योंकि प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस भी तो
करने हैं तो उसके लिए वो खोजता है।
डिप्लॉय रैंसमवेयर अक्रॉस द नेटवर्क और
रैंसमवेयर को डिप्लॉय करना। एक
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में एक कंपनी के अंदर में
अभी का सबसे बड़ा अगर कोई अटैक है तो वो
रैंसवेयर अटैक ही है। जिसमें कि अलग-अलग
डिफरेंट अटैक्स का भी यूज़ किया जाता है।
जैसे कि आपका सोशल इंजीनियरिंग या फिशिंग
इसका यूज़ यूज़ करके यूटिलाइज़ करके
रसवेयर भी प्लांट किया जाता है। एंड
ट्रोजंस को प्लांट किया जाता है। ये सबसे
बड़े अटैक्स होते हैं जनरली कंपनीज़ के
आजकल के अंदर में। ठीक है? और डेटा
ब्रीचेस तो खैर होते ही हैं। जहां पे डेटा
ब्रीच हुई और डेटा जो है डार्क वेब पे सेल
हो रहे होते हैं या डार्क वेब पे पोस्ट कर
दिए जाते हैं। राइट? सो ऑल दिस हैपनिंग इन
अ बिगर लेवल इन अ इन कंपनीज़ नाउ अ डज़ एंड
दिस इज़ द बिगेस्ट अटैक दैट इज़ नोन ऐज़
रैंसवेयर अटैक। तो हर एक प्रोसेस एक अटैकर
करता है। हर एक स्टेप से अटै एक अटैकर
लिया और लास्ट में उसने मान लो अभी यहां
पे रैंसवेयर प्लांट कर दिया। तो ये क्यों
कर रहा है लैटरल मूवमेंट? ताकि
अच्छी-अच्छी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन डाटा मिल जाए
उसको डोमेन कंट्रोलर्स तक मेन तक पहुंच
जाए एडमिन अकाउंट्स को मिल जाए उसको मिल
जाए ताकि वह प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन उसका हो
गया रहेगा तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है एडमिन
प्रिविलेज से वो कुछ भी कर सकता है एंड
रैंसमवेयर को प्लांट कर देता है दैट्स इट
ठीक है
हां अभी मैं बताऊंगा अभी बताऊंगा सब कुछ
अभी पता चल जाएगा वो रैंसमवेयर देखो लैटरल
मूवमेंट और प्रिविज प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
में डिफरेंस है बिल्कुल है मैं आपको
बताऊंगा दोनों का कंसेप्ट भी मैं आपको
बताऊंगा
अटैक पाथ टिपिकल अटैक पाथ क्या होता है
इसमें? जैसे मान लो एक फिशिंग हो गई।
फिशिंग के बाद यूजर का लैपटॉप
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो गया। फिर लैटरल मूवमेंट
होती है वहां पे। डोमेन कंट्रोलर तक इंसान
पहुंचने की कोशिश करता है। एंड फुल
नेटवर्क कंट्रोल जो है वो हो जाता है। तो
यहां पे जब वो लैटरल मूवमेंट कर रहा होता
है तो लैटरल मूवमेंट करता है एडमिन के
अकाउंट्स को एक्सेस करने के लिए या फिर
प्रिविलेज को एस्केलेट करने की कोशिश करने
के लिए। तो लैटरल मूवमेंट वहां पे अभी
आपको जिनका भी क्वेश्चन था यहां से आपको
शायद थोड़ा समझ में आएगा कि दोनों का बीच
का एक माइनर डिफरेंस कितना माइनर डिफरेंस
है जैसे साइबर सिक्योरिटी और एथिकल हैकिंग
का है कि
एक सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम में जाना लेटरल
मूवमेंट कहला रहा है। राइट?
और लैटरल मूवमेंट करने के बाद वह जो अटैकर
है उसने क्या किया? एडमिन अकाउंट्स फाइंड
करने की कोशिश करी। प्रिविलेज को एस्केलेट
करने की कोशिश करी। ठीक है? अब मैं आपको
आगे और भी बताऊंगा। आई विल टेल आई विल टेल
मोर एग्जांपल। जो डिफरेंस यहां पे रका
क्या है? वेद। वेद पॉल उन्होंने पूछा था।
वो और भी क्लियर आपका होगा। अभी रुक जाइए।
कुछ यहां पे एक एग्जांपल मैं आपके लिए
यहां पे एक ड्रा यहां पे एक आपको एक इमेज
मिलेगी। इसमें आपको एग्जांपल एक मिलेगा।
एग्जांपल क्या है? जैसे ये अटैकर है
हमारा। ठीक है? www अपना इंटरनेट ही यूज़
कर रहा है। अटैकर का C2 सर्वर है। कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर है। राइट? यहां पे इसने
एक अह व्हाट हैप? व्हाट ही इज़ डूइंग?
स्पेयर फिशिंग अटैक कर रहा है। स्पेयर
फिशिंग इज़ डूइंग। ठीक है? स्पेयर फिशिंग
करने के बाद क्या होता है? पिरामीटर
इनबाउंड ऑब्वियस सी बात है। इनबाउंड मतलब
कि इनबाउंड कनेक्शंस जो होते हैं फायर वॉल
में फायर वॉल में पता है ना इनबाउंड
आउटबाउंड कनेक्शन होते हैं। इनबाउंड का
मतलब होता है किसी नेटवर्क का इनबाउंड
कनेक्शन। मतलब बाहर से कोई ट्रैफिक आ रही
है। आउटबाउंड का मतलब होता है कि उस
नेटवर्क से ट्रैफिक कोई बाहर की तरफ जा
रही है। तो इनबाउंड आउटबाउंड दीज़ आर द टू
थिंग्स। राइट? सो यहां पे इनबाउंड नेटवर्क
में घुसने के बाद विक्टिम उस पर्टिकुलर
लिंक पे बिना चाहे या जैसा भी हो ट्रैप
में आके क्लिक कर देता है स्पेयर फिशिंग
के लिंक पे। जैसे ही वो क्लिक करता है बॉट
इंस्टॉल हो जाते हैं। बॉट्स जो होते हैं
बैक डोर जो है क्रिएट हो जाता है एंड
कमांड जो है वो रिसीव होने शुरू हो जाते
हैं C2 सर्वर से उस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के
लिए। ठीक है? उस पर्टिकुलर टारगेट के लिए।
तो क्या होता है? जैसे ही बॉट इंस्टॉल
होता है बैकडो इस्टैब्लिश होती है एंड C2
सर्वर जो अटैकर का सर्वर होता है वहां से
कमांड्स इशू करना शुरू कर देता है अटैकर
कि भैया ये करना है वो करना है। नेक्स्ट
स्टेप क्या होता है? स्कैन लैंड फॉर
वनरेबल होस्ट्स टू एक्सप्लइट एंड फाइंड
प्रिविलेज यूज़र्स। अब ये क्या करने लगता
है? पूरे लैंड नेटवर्क को पूरे लैंड
नेटवर्क को क्या करते हैं? स्कैन करने
लगता है। लैंड का मतलब होता है लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क। यानी कि एक नेटवर्क के अंदर
जितने भी डिवाइसेस हैं वो सब लैंड को
फॉर्म करते हैं। अब जैसे आपने राउटर भी
लगाया है। जैसे मेरे यहां पे यहां पे
मैंने राउटर लगा रखा है। ठीक है? अब उस
राउटर से मेरा लैपटॉप भी कनेक्टेड है।
मेरा फोन भी कनेक्टेड है। मेरा आईपैड भी
कनेक्टेड है। मेरा MacBook भी कनेक्टेड
है। मेरा एक और Android फोन है वो भी
कनेक्टेड है। मेरा एक और Android फोन है
वो भी कनेक्टेड है। तो सब कनेक्टेड है आपस
में डिवाइसेस। सो दीज़ आर फॉर्मिंग द लन
नेटवर्क। ठीक है? लन। तो इसको बोलते हैं
लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क। तो अब क्या करते हैं?
लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क्स को यह स्कैन करते
हैं। किस लिए? डिफरेंट काइंड्स ऑफ
एक्सप्लइट्स को फाइंड करने के लिए। जो भी
डिफरेंट काइंड्स ऑफ एक्सप्लइट्स होते हैं
उनको फाइंड करने के लिए ये स्कैन करते
हैं। एंड प्रिविलेज्ड यूज़र्स को फाइंड
करने के लिए स्कैन करते हैं। इनका सिंपल
सा ये होता है कि प्रिविलेज यूजर को फाइंड
करना है। जिसके पास ज्यादा प्रिविलजेस हैं
उनको फाइंड करना है। क्योंकि उसी से काम
चलेगा। अगर प्रिविलेज यूजर फाइंड नहीं कर
पाएंगे तो काम नहीं चल पाएगा। लो लेवल
यूजर्स को फाइंड करके भी क्या फायदा
मिलेगा? ऐसे यूज़र्स को फाइंड करके जिनका
जिनको ज्यादा प्रिविलजेस नहीं है, जो
ज्यादा कुछ कर नहीं सकते हैं वो यूज़र्स को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके भी क्या बेनिफिट डाटाकर
को कोई खास बेनिफिट नहीं है। बट अगर हाई
प्रिविलेज यूजर को फाइंड कर लिया या फिर
एक नॉर्मल लोकल यूजर को हाई प्रिविलेज में
कन्वर्ट कर दिया तो उसका बेनिफिट है। उसके
बाद क्या हो गया कि प्रिविलेज यूजर उसको
मान लो मिल जाता है या लोकल यूजर को
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट्स कर देते हैं जिसको
हम प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कहते हैं। देन
यहां पे एडमिन कंट्रोल्स उनके पास एडमिन
एग्जीकशंस आ जाती हैं। डेटा को
एक्सिल्ट्रेट कर दिया जाता है। डेटा को
चुराया जाता है। एंड उसी डेटा को आउटबाउंड
ट्रैफिक के थ्रू क्या होता है भैया? कि
सिस्टम कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके डेटा को चुरा
लिया जाता है, ब्रीच कर लिया जाता है एंड
बाकी फर्दर जो प्रोसीडिंग्स है वो होती
है। दैट्स इट। तो ये जो पूरा का पूरा
प्रोसेस है दिस प्रोसेस इट शोज़ द लेटरल
मूवमेंट ऑफ द अटैकर। लैटरल मूवमेंट कैसे
शो करता है यहां पे? जब बंदा बॉट इंस्टॉल
करके बंदा लैंड को स्कैन करके एंड
प्रिविलेज यूजर को खोजता है तो वो एक मशीन
से दूसरे मशीनंस में ट्रैवल करता है। एंड
जब एक मशीन से दूसरे मशीन में ट्रैवल करता
है तो उसको हम बोलते हैं लैटरल मूवमेंट।
दिस इज़ द कांसेप्ट्स। अब मुझे बताइए आप
सभी लोग कि आपको यहां तक का कांसेप्ट आप
लोगों का क्लियर हुआ या नहीं हुआ? पहले
मुझे यह बताइए देन वी विल मूव टू द
नेक्स्ट पार्ट। आर यू गेटिंग दिस इज
आर यू गेटिंग? बताइए मुझे। सभी लोग प्लीज
आंसर कीजिए। सो दैट आई गेट टू नो कि व्हाट
यू आर गेटिंग व्हाट यू आर नॉट?
[हंसी] बताइए।
हां हां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बहुत
बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया बहुत अच्छा बहुत अच्छा
काफी काफी लोगों को समझ में आ चुका है
क्या बोल रहे हैं आयुष पटेल क्या बोल रहे
हैं पाइवोटिंग करते हैं ना लैटरल मूवमेंट
के लिए हां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल पाइवोटिंग
पाइवोटिंग करते हैं बिल्कुल उसको
पाइवोटिंग ही बोला जाता है पाइवोटिंग के
थ्रू भी लैटरल मूवमेंट की जाती है। ठीक
है? अगर किसी को नहीं पता तो प्लीज आप
थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा इस पे रिसर्च कीजिएगा।
और वैसे भी मैं बोलता ही हूं कि हर टॉपिक
जो मैं बताता हूं उस पे आपको एक्सप्लोर
करना है। पाइवोटिंग के थ्रू मतलब
पाइवोटिंग का सिंपल सा मतलब होता है कि एक
कॉम्प्रोमाइज्ड सिस्टम के थ्रू दूसरे
सिस्टम्स तक पहुंचना। तो इसी के थ्रू
लैटरल मूवमेंट होता है। तो ये लैटरल
मूवमेंट कहलाता है। जो वो प्रोसेस होता है
उसको हम क्या बोलते हैं? लैटरल मूवमेंट।
जब हम मूव करते हैं लेकिन किसके थ्रू मूव
करते हैं? वो पाइव वोटिंग के थ्रू ही होती
है। ठीक है? आई थिंक यू गॉट।
ओके। ओके। बढ़िया बढ़िया। ओके। तो सभी को
ऑलमोस्ट समझ में आ चुका है इतना।
सभी को समझ में आ गया। ना
ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
डीसीएपीटी में सीखा है पाई वोटिंग अच्छे
से अच्छा आयुष पटेल आप डीसीएपीटी के
स्टूडेंट है चलिए अच्छी बात है हां वहां
पे आपने पाई वोटिंग सीखा होगा क्योंकि
ऑब्वियस सी बात है वो वो भी एक जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग है तो बहुत कुछ सीखा होगा उसमें
आपने। ठीक है? तो यहां पे ये चीजें लैटरल
मूवमेंट यहां पे कंप्लीट हो जाती है। ठीक
है? अब चलिए यहां पे आ जाते हैं लैटरल
मूवमेंट जो है क्यों की जाती है अटैकर्स
के द्वारा? व्हाई लैटरल मूवमेंट इज़
परफॉर्म्ड बाय द अटैकर्स। बिकॉज़ द फर्स्ट
कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम रेयरली हैज़
वैल्यूुएबल डाटा। ऐसा जनरली होता है कि जो
फर्स्ट कॉम्प्रोमाइज सिस्टम होता है उसके
पास ज्यादा
सेंसिटिव डाटा होने के चांसेस बहुत कम
होते हैं। बहुत लिमिटेड होते हैं क्योंकि
वो सबसे ज्यादा वनरेबल होता है एंड वहां
पे आपको अच्छी डेटा प्राइवेट या कुछ ऐसी
सेंसिटिव डेटा मिलेंगे। इसका भी जो है
चांसेस जो है वह थोड़े इसके कम हो जाते
हैं। तो इसलिए एक दूसरे मशीनंस के तरफ
दूसरे मशीनंस के तरफ लैटरल मूवमेंट करना
पड़ता है अटैकर को। एग्जांपल अटैकर
कॉम्प्रोमाइजज़ एंप्लई लैपटॉप। अटैकर ने एक
एंप्लई लैपटॉप को कॉम्प्रोमाइज़ कर लिया।
बट टारगेट इज़ फाइल सर्वर, डोमेन कंट्रोलर,
डेटाबेस सर्वर। टारगेट क्या था? फाइल
सर्वर था, डोमेन कंट्रोलर था, डेटाबेस
सर्वर था। सो, अटैकर मूव्स अक्रॉस द
नेटवर्क। तो अब अटैकर क्या करता है? एक
नेटवर्क से मतलब नेटवर्क के अंदर ही एक
डिवाइस से दूसरे डिवाइस में घूमता है। ये
वही बात हो गई कि ज्ञान मिलने वाली बात हो
गई कि आप ज्ञान की खोज में चले और कहीं भी
आपको ज्ञान नहीं मिल रहा है तो एक शहर से
दूसरे शहर भटक रहे हैं। जैसे कि महात्मा
बुद्ध जो हैं उन्होंने वो एक जगह से दूसरी
जगह भटकते रहे थे। एंड तब जाके जो है उनको
ज्ञान की प्राप्ति बिहार के
बिहार में एक लोकेशन है वहां पे उनको एक
ट्री मतलब पेड़ के नीचे उनको प्राप्ति हुई
थी। ज्ञान की प्राप्ति हुई थी। तो वो भी
बहुत भटके थे। बहुत इधर-उधर गए थे। फिर
जाके उनको ज्ञान की प्राप्ति हुई थी कि
मैं कौन हूं। तो उसी तरीके से आपको भी
ज्ञान की प्राप्ति यहां पे तभी होगी जब आप
एक डिवाइस से दूसरे डिवाइस पे भटक रहे
हैं। लेकिन आपको एक प्रिविलेज डिवाइस मिल
रहा है। एक ऐसा डिवाइस जहां पे सेंसिटिव
इंफॉर्मेशन भी है एंड वो आपके काम का है।
तो जाके आपकी जो है जो आपकी भटकती आत्मा
होगी उसको शांति मिल जाएगी। तो ये काम
करता है अटैकर। दैट्स व्हाई अटैकर परफॉर्म
द लैटरल मूवमेंट। ठीक है? ये आपको क्लियर
हो गया होगा। राइट?
अब आते हैं लैटरल मूवमेंट्स के कुछ कॉमन
टेक्निक्स होते हैं। उनको हम समझते हैं।
अब देखिए यह जो कॉमन टेक्निक्स हैं मैं
आपको बता देता हूं। ये जो कॉमन टेक्निक्स
हैं हां ये कॉमन टेक्निक्स बहुत ही
इंपॉर्टेंट टेक्निक्स हैं। एंड ये कॉमन
टेक्निक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी में बहुत मेजर
टॉपिक्स हैं। बहुत मेजर टॉपिक्स है। साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर में जितने भी
प्रोमिनेंट सर्टिफिकेशंस आप जानते होंगे
उन सब में
इनसे क्वेश्चंस होते हैं। चाहे आप ओएसपी
की भी बात करें तो भी मैं बोल रहा हूं। और
जनरल अगर कोई जेरिक और भी ट्रेनिंग
सर्टिफिकेशंस हैं चाहे वो कॉम्पिया
सिक्योरिटी भी हो या व्हाटएवर ईजीपीटी
वगैरह हो उस सब में इन सब से क्वेश्चंस
होते ही होते हैं। क्योंकि ये बहुत मेजर
टॉपिक्स हैं वहां के लिए। बट फॉर एसओसी एल
वन स्पेशली ये बेसिक आपको जाननी है इनके
बारे में ताकि आप उसको एस्केलेट करने तक
जानकारी रख लें। आप एल2 तक फॉरवर्ड करने
एस्केलेट करने तक की नॉलेज वहां पे रखें।
तो दैट्स व्हाई इट्स वेरीेंट फॉर यू। ठीक
है? अब देखिए
हां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल। चलिए तो
ठीक है।
आपके पढ़ने का तरीका पढ़ाने का तरीका बहुत
अच्छा है।
आपको पढ़ाने का तरीका अच्छा है। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। अच्छा लगा।
चलो ठीक है। ठीक है। ओके। ओके। थैंक्स।
अटैकल स्टील्स पहला इसमें जो टेक्निक है
वो है पास द हैश पी टी एच पास द हैश अटैक
ठीक है ये अटैक से ओएसईपी जैसे ले
एग्जाम्स में भी क्वेश्चंस होते हैं तो
साइबर सिक्योरिटी का हम अभी फिलहाल तो
पार्ट नहीं देख रहे हैं वी आर जस्ट डीलिंग
विद एसओसीएल वन तो जितना नॉलेज आपको चाहिए
मैं दे रहा हूं आपको अच्छे से इसको
समझिएगा पास द हैश टेक्निक लैटरल मूवमेंट
के टेक्निक में क्या होता है अटैकर
स्टील्स पासवर्ड हैशेस फ्रॉम मेमोरी यह
होता है तो लैटरल मूवमेंट करने के लिए
अटैकर क्या करता है कि पासवर्ड हैशेस को
मेमोरी से निकालता है। ऑब्वियस सी बात है
जब पासवर्ड हैश चुरा ली जाएगी अटैकर के
द्वारा इसका मतलब है पासवर्ड कॉम्प्रोमाइज
हो सकता है। पासवर्ड कॉम्प्रोमाइज जब हो
सकता है तो एडमिन के पासवर्ड्स भी
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो सकते हैं। यानी कि एडमिन
एक्सेस मिल सकता है। एंड उस केस में क्या
होगा? एक प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन की सिचुएशन
क्रिएट हो जाएगी। इंस्टेड ऑफ़ क्रैकिंग
पासवर्ड दे रीयूज़ द हैश डायरेक्टली। मतलब
कि पासवर्ड को क्रैक नहीं करना है।
पासवर्ड को मेमोरी से क्या करना है?
चुराना है और पूरे#श को ही यूज़ कर लेना है
ना कि उनको क्रैक करने में ज्यादा टाइम या
ज्यादा फालतू का समय बर्बाद करना है। तो
हैश को यूज़ कर लेते हैं। इसके लिए बहुत
पॉपुलर एक टूल है मिमीज।
ये टूल काफी पॉपुलर है। मिमी कार्ड या
मिमीज जो भी आप पढ़ लें। एंड एक है क्रैक
मैप एग्जैक्ट। तो बहुत सारी टूल्स वैसे
आती हैं बट mmc जो है वन ऑफ द मोस्ट
पॉपुलर टूल यूज्ड इन साइबर सिक्योरिटी
डोमेन फॉर पास द हैश काइंड ऑफ अटैक्स एंड
ये टूल्स यूज़ में लिए जाते हैं। एसओसी का
जो इंडिकेटर है वो क्या कहेगा? एनटीएलएम
ऑथेंटिकेशन एनोमेलिज़ एंड लॉगिन्स विदाउट
पासवर्ड यूसेज। ये एसओसी के इंडिकेटर में
आपको देखने को मिल सकता है कि एनtएलएम
न्यू टेक्नोलॉजी लाइन मैनेजर जो
ऑथेंटिकेशन है उसमें कोई गड़बड़ी आई है
एनोमैलीज है कुछ कुछ एरर्स हैं कुछ
गड़बड़ी है या तो लॉगिनस हो रहे हैं बट
बिना पासवर्ड के यूज़ के लॉग इन हो रहे
हैं मतलब लॉगिन विदाउट द पासवर्ड यूज़ तो
ये एसओसी के इंडिकेटर जो हैं वो बताएंगे|
हां मिमिकैट्स बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट टूल
है मिडज के लिए कोई पैसा नहीं देना होता
है अब्सोलुटली फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट दिस टूल इज
अब
यहां पे दूसरा जो आपका टेक्निक है वो है
पास द टिकट अटैक जिसको हम करबेरॉस अटैक
बोलते हैं। करबेरॉस अटैक इज़ द नेटवर्क
वेरी पॉपुलर अह नेटवर्क अटैक टेक्निक। तो
पास द टिकट जो है यह अटैक क्या होता है?
अटैकर स्टील्स करबेरस ऑथेंटिकेशन टिकट्स।
करबेरस इज़ अ सर्विस दैट इज़ बीइंग वाइडली
यूज्ड बाय ऑर्गेनाइजेशंस। तो फॉर
ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑब्वियस सी बात है। ऑथेंटिकेशन
के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है। तो ये क्या
किया जाता है? कर्वेरॉस ऑथेंटिकेशन टिकट्स
को चुराने का काम करना है। मतलब वो जैसे
मान लो एक आपने आपने देखा हो ना कि जैसे
एक अ सीक्रेट की होती है। राइट? सीक्रेट
की होती है। जैसे कोई अगर एपीआई या किसी
तरह का कोई एपीआई एक्सेस आपको या एपीआईज़
मिल जाती हैं तो उसको एक्सेस करने के लिए
आपको एक सीक्रेट आईडी सीक्रेट की
वगैरह-वगैरह कुछ होता है। उसी तरीके से
करबेरस ऑथेंटिकेशन के टिकट्स होते हैं। उन
टिकट्स को कॉम्प्रोमाइज अगर किसी ने कर
लिया तो उस मशीन को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लेगा।
तो यहां पे बेसिकली अटैकर ट्राई करता है
कि उस करबेरॉस ऑथेंटिकेशन टिकट को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज या चुरा लिया जाए। देन यूज़
देम टू एक्सेस अदर मशीन। अब उस बेसिकली उस
टिकट का यूज करके क्योंकि करबेरॉस जो है
जनरली जब आप एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी वगैरह जब
आप पढ़ेंगे जब आप डोमेनस की बात करेंगे तो
वहां पे जैसे ही टिकट का कॉम्प्रोमाइज
कॉम्प्रोमाइज होता है तो दूसरे मशीनंस को
भी वहां से एक्सेस किया जा सकता है। इसलिए
ये काफी एक इंपॉर्टेंट चीज होती है। एंड
काफी ज्यादा डेंजरस अटैक होता है पास द
टिकट। तो यहां पे जब इस इस अटैक को लांच
किया जाता है तो लेटरल मूवमेंट के लिए यह
इस्तेमाल किया जा सकता है। जहां पे एक
मशीन से फिर बाकी के जो मशीनंस हैं उसके
अंदर वो सबको एक्सेस किया जाना चाहेगा जो
हमारा अटैकर है। एसोसिएट इंडिकेटर क्या
बोलेगा? सस्िशियस करबेरॉस टिकट यूसेस कि
मतलब करबेरॉस का सस्िशियस टिकट यूज़ हुआ
है। यू अनयूजुअल टीजीटी एक्टिविटी।
अनयूजुअल टीजीटी एक्टिविटी जो कि उसी
कॉर्पोरेट्स ऑथेंटिकेशन का ही पार्ट है।
तो वो एक अनयुअल एक्टिविटी हो रहा है। अब
यहां पे मैं आपको एक चीज बताऊंगा कि
करबेरॉस के बारे में थोड़ा सा पढ़
लीजिएगा। थोड़ी सी एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा।
ये एक अलग सेपरेट टॉपिक है। यू डोंट नीड
टू गो डीप इनसाइड क्योंकि जाओगे तो जाते
रह जाओगे। ये एक बहुत बड़ा टॉपिक है
करबेरॉस। एंड इसमें इसके अंदर ही बहुत
सारी चीजें हैं। यू कैन नॉट अंडरस्टैंड
सिंपली क्योंकि आप घुसोगे तो वो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का पार्ट है। उसमें आपकी
रिक्वायरमेंट इतनी नहीं है। एल1 के लिए
कुछ भी आपको मोटा-मोटी हल्काफुल्का नॉलेज
बस जितना मैं आपको बता रहा हूं उतना काफी
है। बस दैट्स इट। बस करबेरॉस क्या होता
है? इस करबेरॉस अटैक क्या होते हैं? बस ये
थोड़ा बहुत जानकारी आपको होगा। चलेगा। जो
भी मैं टॉपिक यहां पे बता रहा हूं जैसे कि
लेटरल मूवमेंट के टेक्निक्स जो बता रहा
हूं जैसे पास द हैश। तो थोड़ा बहुत पास द
हैश को एक्सप्लोर कर लीजिएगा। अभी मैं
आपको तो सब सब कुछ सब कुछ मैं आपको बता
रहा हूं। अभी अभी जो भी चीजें
रिक्वायरमेंट है समझाने वाली बात है वो
मैं आपको समझा रहा हूं। बट आपको खुद से भी
और थोड़ा डिटेल में एक्सप्लोर करना है
ताकि आप रेडी हो सके उस लेवल के लिए जो हम
जॉब रेडी लेवल बोलते आ रहे हैं। बस मैं
यही बोलूंगा। ठीक है? हां अब देखिए
हां बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सिस्टम डोमेन हां
डोमेनस के केस में होता है यहां पे। तो अब
यहां पे जब एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स आपके आ
जाएंगे तो ये एसोसिए इंडिकेटर्स आपको
देखने को मिलेंगे। जनरली जो टूल्स आप भी
जो भी लाइक जो भी या बिल्कुल वही मैंने
बोला कि जब आप एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी वगैरह
डील करते हैं एंड डोमेनस की बात करते हैं
तब आप करबेरॉस की बात करेंगे एंड तभी आपको
कर्वबेरस से सामना होगा। ऐसे आपको कोई भी
सामना कर्वबेरस का आपसे नहीं होने वाला
है। ठीक है? तो ये एसओसी के इंडिकेटर्स
हैं जो आपको देखने को मिलेगा जो भी आप
टूल्स या एसआईएम टूल्स यूज़ कर रहे हैं।
तीसरा जो दूसरा नेक्स्ट जो आपका अ टेक्निक
होता है रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल का यूज़
करके टेक्निक होता है आरडीपी का यूज़ करके
रिमोट डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल। अब देखो रिमोट
डेस्कटॉप प्रोटोकॉल का एक फिक्स्ड पोर्ट
नंबर होता है जिसको कि हम बोलते हैं 3389
जैसे आपका एचटीटीp 80 पोर्ट पे काम करता
है। एसटीडी
पीएस जो है आपका 443 पे काम करता है। उसी
तरीके से जो आपका आरडीपी प्रोटोकॉल है वो
3389 पे काम करता है। 3389 पोर्ट पे। ठीक
है? अब 3389 पोर्ट पे जब काम करता है तो
अटैकर क्या करता है? यूज स्टोलन
क्रेडेंशियल्स टू कनेक्ट वाया पोर्ट 3389।
अटैकर क्या ट्राई करता है कि किसी आरडीपी
का क्रेडेंशियल चुराया हुआ यूज करने की
कोशिश करता है। अब आरडीपी के थ्रू आप एक
सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम को कनेक्ट कर सकते
हैं। जैसे अगर मैं अपने आरडीपी मैंने
अपने-अपने सिस्टम पे अगर मान लो कि आरडीपी
की सर्विस स्टार्ट कर दी है। तो मेरे
सिस्टम के आईपी से अगर कोई चाहे कनेक्ट
करना तो इस पोर्ट पे मेरे सिस्टम के आईपी
से कनेक्ट करके आरडीपी प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू
मेरे सिस्टम का एक्सेस ले सकता है। वो
इनफैक्ट ग्राफिकल एक्सेस भी ले सकता है।
एंड पूरी कंप्लीट एक्सेस जैसे मेरे पास
अगर एडमिन एक्सेस है तो उसके पास भी एडमिन
एक्सेस होगा। तो यह काफी डेंजरस होता है।
हालांकि देयर आर सम सिक देयर आर मल्टीपल
मेनी सिक्योरिटी मेजर्स बट स्टिल अगर
अटैकर जो है क्रेडेंशियल चुरा लेता है ऐसा
सक्सेसफुल हो जाता है तो इस पोर्ट पे
कनेक्ट करके वो आरडीपी सर्विस से जो है वो
कनेक्ट कर लेता है। एसओसी इंडिकेटर में
क्या होते हैं भैया? इंटरनल आरडीपी
कनेक्शंस, अनयुअल लॉग इन लोकेशनेशंस, लॉग
इन आउटसाइड वर्किंग आवर्स। ये जो है आपके
एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स में देखने को मिल जाते
हैं। इंटरनल आरडीपी कनेक्शंस हो रहे हैं।
आरडीपी के मल्टीपल कनेक्शंस बन रहे हैं।
अनयूजुअल लॉग इन लोकेशनेशंस आ रहे हैं
भैया। अरे भैया कहीं-कहीं से लोकेशन से
लॉग इन हो रहा है तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है
अनयूजुअल लॉग इन लोकेशनेशंस होंगे। एंड
लॉग इन आउटसाइड वर्किंग आवर्स। वर्किंग
आवर क्योंकि अब कोई ट्रैकर लॉग इन करेगा
तो वर्किंग आवर थोड़ी ना देखेगा। वो कहीं
से भी कहीं से भी कभी भी कनेक्ट करने की
कोशिश करेगा। ठीक है। हां जी बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल कमेंट कर दिया करो। देन हमारा
नेक्स्ट टेक्निक है एसएमबी
Windows एडमिन शेयर्स। ये काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग अ टेक्निक है Windows एडमिन
शेयर्स का या एसएमबी जिसको हम बोलते हैं
सर्वर मैसेज ब्लॉक। काफी एक इंटरेस्टिंग
सर्विस है। जहां से आप शेयरर्ड फोल्डर्स
को डायरेक्टरीज़ को एक्सेस कर सकते हैं। एक
एक लाइन के अंदर में लोकल इंडियन नेटवर्क
के अंदर में वैन के अंदर में आप ये नहीं
कर सकते। लाइन के अंदर में आप कर सकते
हैं। जनरली क्या होता है कि सर्वर मैसेज
ब्लॉक एक ऐसी सर्विस है जहां से आप जिसके
यूज़ से जनरली Windows के अंदर में आप
जितने भी शेयरर्ड फोल्डर है जैसे कोई
फोल्डर हुआ उसको आपने शेयर किया हुआ है तो
उसको एक्सेस जो है वो कर सकते हैं। अब मैं
शेयर्ड फोल्डर की बात किस तरीके से कर रहा
हूं मैं आपको थोड़ा सा इसका
ओवरव्यू दे देता हूं। जैसे मान लो कि ये
बबशूट का फोल्डर है। मैं इसको राइट क्लिक
करता हूं यहां पे। राइट? यहां पे मैं
प्रॉपर्टीज पे जाता हूं। जब आप प्रॉपर्टी
जाएंगे किसी भी फोल्डर के तो यहां पे आपको
दिखेगा राइट अ मल्टीपल ऑप्शंस ऊपर दिखते
हैं यहां पे एंड यहां पे शेयरिंग का एक
ऑप्शन दिखता है राइट शेयरिंग के ऑप्शन पे
जाएंगे तो आपको दिखेगा कि नेटवर्क पाथ पे
नॉट शेयरर्ड लिखा है ये फोल्डर यानी कि ये
फोल्डर शेयरर्ड नहीं है। दिस इज़ नॉट
शेयरर्ड फोल्डर। नेटवर्क पे ये शेयरर्ड
नहीं है लोकल एरिया नेटवर्क पे। यानी कि
दूसरा सिस्टम इसको एक्सेस नहीं कर सकता
है। अभी आप लोकल सिस्टम पे ही ओनली एक्सेस
कर सकते हो। जब शेयर पे क्लिक करोगे तो
यहां से आप इसकी शेयरिंग को कंट्रोल कर
सकते हो या फिर आप यहां पे एडवांस शेयरिंग
पे जाके कस्टम परमिशंस जो हैं या मल्टीपल
शेयर्स वगैरह जो हैं या दो जो भी एडवांस
ऑप्शंस है वो सेटअप कर सकते हो। जैसे आप
एडवांस शेयर पे जाओगे तो आप यहां पे एक
ऑप्शन मिलेगा शेयर दिस फोल्डर। तो शेयर
दिस फोल्डर पे क्लिक कर दोगे और यहां पे
शेयर नाम आएगा फोल्डर का जो भी नाम है
आपने वो नाम दे दिया यहां पे। अब यहां पे
लिमिट द नंबर ऑफ़ साइमलटेनियस यूज़र्स।
कितने साइमलटेनियस यूज़र्स इसको एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं। तो 20 यहां पे दे रखा है। आप
इसको कम ज़्यादा जो भी करना है वो आप मतलब
जो भी कम ज़्यादा करना है वो कर सकते हो।
एंड देन यहां पे परमिशंस पे आप क्लिक
करोगे तो आप परमिशंस यहां पे दे सकते हो
इसके लिए कि भैया ग्रुप और यूजरनेम्स। तो
अभी किसके लिए ये शेयर्ड है? एवरीवन सबके
लिए शेयरर्ड है। बट अगर आपको स्पेसिफिक
कोई शेयर्ड अ आपको परमिशन देनी है तो यहां
पे अभी फिलहाल के लिए एवरीवन के लिए क्या
है? ये ओनली रीड का परमिशन है। ठीक है? बट
आपको इसको फुल कंट्रोल देना है। एवरीवन को
राइट चेंज कुछ भी देना है तो आप इसको टिक
करेंगे तो ये जो है ये अलऊ में फुल
कंट्रोल चेंज रीड सब कुछ अलाउ हो जाएगा।
अगर ओनली रीड का देना है तो ओनली रीड रहने
दीजिए। अब एवरीवन के अलावा कोई और भी है
जिसको आप देना चाहते हैं तो आप ऐड पे
क्लिक करेंगे तो यहां पे आप ऐड करेंगे तो
आप क्या-क्या सेलेक्ट कर सकते हैं? यूज़र्स
को सेलेक्ट कर सकते हैं, ग्रुप्स को
एक्सेस दे सकते हैं या बिल्ट इन
सिक्योरिटी प्रिंसिपल्स को मतलब चूज़ कर
सकते हैं। तो यहां पे मैं जनरली किसी को
भी कोई किसको शेयर किया जाता है? कोई भी
चीज यूज़र्स को या तो ग्रुप्स को यानी कि
एक यूजर को शेयर होगा कोई फोल्डर या कोई
फाइल या तो एक ग्रुप जिसमें मल्टीपल
यूज़र्स होंगे उन सबको शेयर किया जाएगा। तो
अब मुझे मान लो कोई यूज़र्स को करना है। तो
अब यहां पे यहां पे आप देख सकते हो यहां
पे एडवांस पे क्लिक करेंगे। अब यहां पे
एडवांस पे क्लिक करेंगे तो यहां पे मेरे
पास फाइंड नाउ का एक ऑप्शन मिल जाएगा। अब
फाइंड नाउ पे मैं क्लिक करूंगा तो मेरे को
जितने भी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स पीसी के अंदर में
यूज़र्स ग्रुप्स हैं वो सारे यहां पे शो कर
देंगे। तो आप देखो यहां पे यूज़र्स एंड
ग्रुप जितने भी हैं यहां पे शो हो गए हैं।
अब मेरे पास जिसको भी मैं एक्सेस देना
चाहता हूं। मान लो एक जो है यहां पे आपका
देखो यहां पे यहां पे ये जो है ना एक
सिंगल एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एक यूजर है। ठीक है?
यहां पे मल्टीपल में ग्रुप्स बने हुए हैं।
ठीक है? अब यहां पे देखो जैसे एक सिंगल ये
यूजर है। जो ये फोटो देख रहे हो ना एक
सिंगल फोटो दिख रही है आपको। तो ये एक
यूजर है। सिंगल यूजर है। ठीक है? तो ये
यूजर हो गया। फिर गेस्ट जो है ये आपका एक
यूजर हो गया। उसी तरह का एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एक आपका यूजर हो गया। बाकी जो है ग्रुप्स
हैं। जैसे अ
डिफ़ॉल ये भी एक यूजर है। जैसे ये
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स ये एक ग्रुप है। ठीक है?
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ये एक यूजर है। ये एक
एनोनिमस लॉगन ये करके एक ग्रुप है। ठीक
है? ये ऑथेंटिकेशन ये ग्रुप है। तो ये दीज़
आर सम ग्रुप्स एंड सम यूज़र्स आर देयर। तो
जिसको भी एक्सेस देना है आप उसको सेलेक्ट
कर सकते हैं। एंड यहां से जैसे मान लो कि
मुझे अ
डिफ्रॉनिक्स यूजर को देना है। अभी तो सबके
लिए है बट मुझे ओनली डिफ़्रॉनिक्स को अगर
देना है तो मैं यहां पे डिफ़ॉन सेलेक्ट
करके यहां पे ओके कर दूंगा। सो आई हैव गॉट
द डिफ़्रॉनिक्स यूजर हियर एंड मैं यहां पे
ओके कर दूंगा। अब मैं यहां पे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
के लिए कस्टम से जो है अ शेयरिंग परमिशंस
जो है परमिशंस जो है सेटअप कर सकता हूं
यहां पे। अब मैं एवरीवन को चाहें तो मैं
एवरीवन को रिमूव कर सकता हूं या फिर
एवरीवन का परमिशंस हटा सकता हूं। जो भी
परमिशन है हटा सकता हूं। फिलहाल इसके पास
तो कोई वैसे भी परमिशन नहीं थी। रीड का
ओनली परमिशन था। चलेगा। रीड का परमिशन
ओनली हो तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। बट अगर
मैं डिफ्रॉनिक्स को चाहूं तो मैं रीड राइट
फुल कंट्रोल मतलब रीड राइट चेंज कुछ भी
सबका दे सकता हूं। एंड इंडिविजुअल जो है
वो करके इसको अप्लाई जैसे ही करूंगा ये
शेयरर्ड हो जाएगा। एंड उसके बाद इसको
नेटवर्क पाथ पे जो है एक्सेस किया जा
सकेगा। ठीक है? ठीक है? क्योंकि एवरीवन है
तो हर कोई इसको एक्सेस कर सकता है। दैट्स
द मेन फंडा। ठीक है? चलिए अब मैं यहां पे
क्लिक करता हूं। जैसे ही मैं शेयर करता
यहां पे आ जाता शेयरर्ड और उस नेटवर्क पाथ
पे ये शेयरर्ड हो जाता। अब मैं यहां पे
जैसे एडवांस शेयरिंग पे मैं यहां पे शेयर
करके यहां पे मैं परमिशंस पे करता हूं।
मैं यहां पे अगर फुल कंट्रोल कर देता हूं।
मैं यहां पे अप्लाई करता हूं। ओके करता
हूं। एंड मैं अप्लाई करके ओके कर दूंगा।
तो यहां पे आप दिख आपको दिख रहा होगा कि
यह इस नेटवर्क पाथ पे फॉर स्लश
डिफ्रॉनिक्स बबूट pro इस पे जो है वो
शेयरर्ड हो चुका है। एंड यहां से ये
एक्सेस किया जा सकता है। फिर से अगर आपको
लेट्स सपोज हटाना है सिंपल एडवांस शेयरिंग
पे जाइए। शेयर दिस फोल्डर को रिमूव कीजिए।
अप्लाई कीजिए। ये ओके कीजिए। ओके कीजिए।
एंड दैट्स इट। द शेयर्ड जो है वो रिमूव हो
चुकी है। तो इस तरीके से क्या हो सकता है?
आप शेयरिंग वगैरह जो है इनेबल करते हैं।
एंड इन्हीं शेयरर्ड फोल्डर को एक्सेस करने
के लिए शेयरर्ड रिसोर्सेज डायरेक्टरीज़ को
एक्सेस करने के लिए आप एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल
का यूज़ करते हैं Windows के अंदर में सब
मैसेज ब्लॉक को। अब एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल के
अंदर में कई सारी वनेबिलिटीज़ पास्ट में आई
हैं। कई सारे
उस [हंसी] पे बेस्ड एक्सप्लइट्स अवेलेबल
है मार्केट में जिसका इस्तेमाल हैकर्स
करते हैं टू गेट एक्सेस टू द शेयरर्ड
फोल्डर्स। जब एक बार किसी नेटवर्क में एक
अटैकर घुस जाता है, वह ट्राई करता है
एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल को एक्सप्लइट करके एंड
जितने भी शेयर डायरेक्टरीज फोल्डर हैं
उनको एक्सेस करने का। वो बस इतना ही ट्राई
करता है। तो दिस इज़ कॉल्ड एसएमबी Windows
एडमिन शेयर अटैकर कॉपीज़ टूल्स अक्रॉस
मशीनंस यूजिंग टारगेट सी फलाना। मतलब मतलब
क्या करता है कि ये शेयरर्ड एक लोकेशनेशंस
पे अलग-अलग मशीनंस में क्या करता है। अगर
sएबी एक्सप्लइट किया उसने तो वो अपने
टूल्स जो है वो कॉपी कर देता है क्योंकि
उसको ऑब्वियस सी बात है मशीनंस का एक्सेस
मिल चुका है। शेयरर्ड एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल
इनेबल्ड है जिससे कि जितने भी मशीनंस हैं
आपस में कनेक्टेड हैं और उसके बाद ये उन
टूल्स को कॉपी कर देता है उसका यूज़ करके।
कॉमन टूल्स क्या है? पीएस एग्जीक्यू
एग्जैक्ट इंपैकेट क्रैक मैप एग्जैक्ट या
फिर आपका कौन सा टूल था? वो मिमी कैच। तो
डिफरेंट जो अटैकिंग टूल्स हैं जो भी टूल्स
यूज़ में लिए जाते हैं उनको को कॉपी करने
का काम वो करता है। तो इसके लिए एसएमबी का
यूज़ में एसएमबी का वो यूज़ करता है।
इंडिकेटर्स क्या बोलेंगे? एडमिन शेयर
एक्सेस जो है उसका इंडिकेटर आपको आएगा।
सस्िशियस फाइल ट्रांसफर का एक्सेस आपको
इंडिकेटर आएगा और सर्विस क्रिएशन इवेंट्स
आएंगे कि अलग-अलग सर्विज जो है वो क्रिएट
हो रहे हैं। तो दीज़ टाइप ऑफ इंडिकेटर्स यू
विल सी इन फॉर द एज एन एसओसीएल वन इन द एस
एसआईएम टूल्स। एसआईएम जो टूल आप यूज़ करते
हैं उसमें ये इंडिकेटर्स आपको शो होंगे
फॉर दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग। उसके बाद लास्ट
में हमारा एक आता है और Windows मैनेजमेंट
इंस्ट्रूमेंटेशन डब्ल्यू एमआई।
डब्ल्यूएमआई जो है वो काफी अच्छा एक टूल
टूल है। यू कैन से अलऊ रिमोट कमांड
एग्जीक्यूशन जिसकी की मदद से आप रिमोट
कमांड को एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं। Windows
मैनेजमेंट इंस्ट्रूमेंटेशन डब्ल्यूएमआई
कमांड से। ठीक है? कई लोगों ने WMआई सी को
यूज़ भी किया होगा। WMIC जो है अ आई थिंक
एक बहुत पॉपुलर कमांड मैं बोलूंगा बट कई
लोगों को शायद नहीं पता होती है इसके बारे
में बट इट इज़ अ वेरी वेरी ग्रेट टूल इन
Windows WMIC अगर आप वैसे देखना चाहें तो
आप वैसे
इफ यू वांट यू कैन सी द लाइक हेल्प एंड ऑल
तो डब्ल्यू एमआईसी
ओके यहां पर इसको अभी ओके दिस इज नॉट नॉट
प्रेजेंट अभी यहां पर यह अभी इसमें ओपन
नहीं होगा बट WMIC को आप ओपन कर लीजिएगा
इनेबल कर लीजिएगा एक बार इनेबल करके आप
उसको ओपन कर सकते हैं देन यू कैन सी कि
WMIC में वह बहुत सारे ऑप्शंस होते हैं
कमांड्स ऑप्शंस होते हैं जहां पे आप उसको
चलाएंगे तो यू विल गेट अ लॉट ऑफ़ ऑप्शंस अ
लॉट ऑफ अ थिंग्स टू डू विद द WMIC कमांड
तो आप बस उसको इनेबल कर लीजिएगा एक बार
इनेबल करके आप चलाइएगा तो क्या होगा कि आप
इस कमांड के थ्रू रिमोट कमांड्स मतलब
रिमोट कमांड एग्जीक्यूशन में इसकी हेल्प
ले सकते हैं डब्ल्यूएमआईसी की। तो ये काफी
डेंजरस हो जाता है जब आप किसी सिस्टम पे
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाता है। तो एस इंडिकेटर
में क्या आएगा? डब्ल्यूएमआई प्रोसेस
क्रिएशन एंड रिमोट एग्जीक्यूशन लॉक। तो
WMआई को स्टार्ट करने का यहां पे
इंडिकेटर्स में आएगा कि भैया WMIC जो
सर्विस है उसको स्टार्ट किया गया है।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है मेरे सिस्टम पे वो
सर्विस स्टार्ट नहीं है तो इसलिए वो ओपन
नहीं हुआ है। बट जब आप सर्विस को स्टार्ट
कर देंगे तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है वहां पे ये
काम करना लगेगा। तो इस तरीके से क्या होता
है जब लैटरल मूवमेंट के अंदर में जो अटैकर
होता है वो डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टाइप्स से
ट्राई करता है आपके सिस्टम में घुसने का।
आपके एक सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम में जाने
का। बस मेन उसका वही मुद्दा है। राइट? एंड
मेन यही काम उसको करना है। उसके अलावा कोई
काम उसको नहीं करना है। जैसे ही वो एक
सिस्टम से दूसरे सिस्टम में जा रहा है। एक
मशीन से दूसरे मशीन में जा रहा है,
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट कर पा रहा है। देन
वहीं पे वो लैटरल मूवमेंट कर पा रहा है।
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कर पा रहा है। एंड वो
कंप्रोमाइज कर पा रहा है। डेटा एक्सप्रेट
रेट कर पा रहा है। ये पूरा का पूरा एक
प्रोसेस होता है। ठीक है? आई थिंक कि आप
इतना समझ में आपको आ गया होगा। अभी तक
मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए जल्दी से। सभी को
समझ में आ गया।
सभी लोग बताइए प्लीज।
ओके एवरीवन एवरीवन गॉट इट
ठीक है ठीक है ओके चलिए अच्छी बात है
अच्छी बात है
हेल्प डेस्क जॉइ तो कर सकते हो बट कुछ खास
बेनिफिट आपको नहीं मिलेगा
सर आपके आपके अलावा YouTube में अ एसओसी
जैसा कोई नहीं पढ़ा था। मैं लॉग एनालिसिस
का वीडियो देख के थक गया बट अभी तक नहीं
मिला। कोई बात नहीं लॉग एनालिसिस की
वीडियो आएगी। यहीं पे आएगी।
बिल्कुल आएगी।
देखो
देखो जब विंडोज में मैं आपको बता देता
हूं।
आई रेगुलरली पोस्ट ऑल नोट्स ऑन GH आई
पोस्टेड टिल क्लास नाइन ओके ग्रेट बहुत
अच्छी बात है गिट पे आपने डाला है तो
Lindin पे एक बार डाल के टैग कर दीजिएगा
गीब का लिंक भी डाल दीजिएगा ताकि हमें भी
पता चले कहां पे आप डालते हैं
सर कैन यू प्लीज क्लियर नेटवर्किंग बेसिक
फॉर एसओसी एल वन प्लीज प्लीज यस यस वो भी
होगा यार एसओ एसओसी लेवल वन के लिए
नेटवर्किंग का जो पार्ट है वो भी मैं लेकर
आऊंगा सब कुछ होगा
ठीक है
देखो Windows में जिनको नहीं पता है
सीएमडी में ठीक है कोई भी कमांड चलाओगे ना
कोई भी कमांड जैसे मैंने डब्ल्यूएमआईसी का
चेक करा क्योंकि ये इनेबल नहीं है तो मेरा
अभी आ नहीं रहा था उसके बाद स्लैश
क्वेश्चन मार्क दे दोगे तो उसकी हेल्प
फाइल खुल जाएगी उस कमांड की जब भी वो
कमांड वर्किंग होगा ठीक है तो उसकी हेल्प
फाइल ओपन हो जाएगी तो हेल्प फाइल से आप
देख सकते हो उस कमांड का वर्किंग क्या
प्रोसीजर क्या है कैसे है क्या है ठीक है
अभी ये डब्ल्यूएमआईसी नॉट रिकॉग्नाइज आ
रहा है क्योंकि ये इनेबल नहीं होगा जैसे
आप सिंपल कंट्रोल पैनल देखो मैं इस पे
इसलिए नहीं आ रहा कि क्योंकि क्योंकि अभी
ये आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट नहीं है। कंट्रोल
पैनल में ये ऑप्शनल फीचर में डब्ल्यूएमआई
को आप देख लीजिएगा यहां पे। टर्न यहां पे
डब्ल्यूएमआई का कहीं ना कहीं कुछ होगा।
या तो पाथ की पाथ नहीं होगी।
कहां गए भाई डब्ल्यूएमआई
ओके इसका हो सकता है पाथ सेट नहीं होगा इस
वजह से आपको मिल नहीं रहा हो ये काम नहीं
कर रहा होगा अ
प्रोसेस एक्टिवेशन
नेट फ्रेमवर्क कॉन्फिग एपीआई ठीक है अह
नहीं एडमिशन नहीं पाथ एक्टिव नहीं होगा
पाथ एक्टिव नहीं होगा मैं एक पावर सेल से
चेक कर लेता हूं कि उसमें आती है कि नहीं।
हम हम हम
wmआई सी लेट्स सी इसमें नहीं इसमें भी
नहीं है। अ ठीक है। हो सकता है इसका पाथ
एक्टिव नहीं होगा। अ सी विंडज सिस्टम 32
सिस्टम 32 कहां है भैया हमारे? सिस्टम 32
सिस्टम 32 सिस्टम 32 ये रहा
डब्ल्यू एम
हियर इज़ द प्रोसेस
ओके
अ
डब्ल्यू
ओके
इसमें आपको
डब्ल्यूएमआई
हां आई थिंक ये पाथ सेट नहीं है शायद मे
बी
हम हम हम हम हम हम
यहां तो था बट स्टिल फिर भी
लेट्स सी
हम अभी तो ये इसका वही है। wmआईसी इंस्टॉल
नहीं है। ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं है। अ
नहीं है। ये अभी ऐसे नहीं चलेगा। इसका कुछ
पाथ का गड़बड़ होगा। कुछ पाथ की गड़बड़ी
होगी इसलिए होगी। अदरवाइज ये आपके वैसे
अगर पाथ का गड़बड़ी नहीं होगा तो आपकी चल
जाएगी। अगर आपात की गड़बड़ी नहीं होगी
आपके सिस्टम में। आपके सिस्टम में चलाएगी।
कोई अगर सिस्टम से है तो आप चेक चला के एक
बार देख लीजिएगा। ठीक है? तो दैट इज दैट
विल बी अ लाइक वो चलेगा। या तो फिर
सर्विसेस जो है अ
सर्विसेस देख लेते हैं एक बार।
लेट इट ओपन।
हम यहां से देख लेते हैं। शायद यहां नहीं
हो।
अ wmआई अप्टर अ परफॉर्मेंस अप्टर आई थिंक
wmआई का
ऑल स्टार्ट करते हैं इसको। एक बार स्टार्ट
करते हैं।
रनिंग हो गया। नाउ लेट्स सी इफ दैट इज़
रनिंग ऑ नॉट।
ओके डब्ल्यू एमआईसी नहीं अभी भी
नहीं अभी भी नहीं चल रहा है ये तो एक बार
फीचर्स स्टार्ट करके देख लेते हैं
सिक्योरिटी
इसमें वैसे ज्यादा टाइम हम देंगे नहीं
क्योंकि लेट्स सी
हम हम
प्रोसेस मॉडल्स
ओके देयर इज नथिंग
हम
एक काम करते हैं।
डब्ल्यूएमआईआई को यहां से देख लेते हैं।
लेट्स सी
ओके ये डिप्रिसिएट हो चुका है। दैट्स
व्हाई ये रीज़न था नहीं आने का यहां पे। अ
द थिंग इज़ कि इसलिए मैंने यहां पे सोचा कि
सर्च करके एक बार देख ही लेता हूं क्योंकि
ऐसे जनरली तो मिल जाती है बट ये नहीं मिल
रही थी। इसका रीज़न अब समझ में आ गया। द
WMआई कमांड लाइन WMIC जो है बेसिकली
यूटिलिटी इज़ डेप्रिसिएटेड एज ऑफ़ Windows
10 वर्जन 21H1 एंड एज ऑफ़ द 21H1 सेमी
एनुअल चैनल रिलीज़ ऑफ़ Windows सर्वर। दिस
यूटिलिटी इज़ सब अह सुपरसीडेड बाय Windows
पावर शेल फॉर WMI. ठीक है? तो दिस अप्लाई
अप्लाई ओनली टू द Wmआईसी कमांड लाइन
यूटिलिटी Windows मैनेजर इटसेल्फ इज़ नॉट
अफेक्टेड WMआई तो ये कमांड यूटिलिटी जो है
उसके मतलब ये वो वो हो गया है डिप्रिशिएट
कर दिया गया है दैट्स व्हाई यहां पे आपको
देखने को मिल नहीं रहा है कुछ भी एंड ये
आपका कमांड लाइन यूटिलिटी था जहां से आप
इसको एक्सेस कर सकते थे ठीक है तो हालांकि
आप डायरेक्टली वैसे भी इंस्टॉल करके भी कर
सकते थे पहले वैसे भी फिर आप डायरेक्टली
आपको मिल जाती थी तो अब यहां पे ये नो लगर
डेवलपिंग िंग एंड ऑल। तो ये डेप्रिसिएशन
है। डेप्रिसिएशन हो चुकी है। तो इस वजह से
आपको यहां पे देखने को नहीं मिल रही थी।
चलिए तो ये मुझे डाउट तो था बट स्टिल
मैंने सोचा कंफर्म एक बार कर ही लेते हैं।
एंड कंफर्म हमने कर लिया। तो यहां पे इस
तरीके से क्या करता है वो? रिमोट कोड का
एग्जीक्यूशन करने में हेल्प लेता है। ये
एक टेक्निक होता है। जब वो लैटरल मूवमेंट
करता है तो वो ट्राई करता है रिमोट कोड
एग्जीक्यूशन करने का। जो भी आपका अटैकर है
वो सिस्टम्स के ऊपर में ताकि वो रिमोट कोड
को एग्जीक्यूट करके क्या कर सकता है? उस
केस में दे कैन डू एनी काइंड ऑफ़ थिंग दे
कैन रिमोटली कंप्रोमाइज दे कैन एग्जीक्यूट
सम काइंड ऑफ़ आर्बिटरी
मलिशियस कोड्स मशियस कमांड्स एक्सट्रा
एक्सट्रा तो इस वजह से ये चीज़ होती है। अब
रियल एसओसी सिनेरियो की जब हम बात करते
हैं तो रियल एसोसिएट सिनेरियो क्या होता
है यहां पे? अलर्ट सीक्वेंस क्या होती है
उसमें? मैं आपको यह समझाने की कोशिश करता
हूं। ठीक है?
नहीं डब्ल्यू एमआईसी को डेप्रिशिएट कर
दिया गया है। दैट्स इसलिए वहां पे हमें
नहीं मिल रहा है। उसको हटा दिया वो
यूटिलिटी को ही हटा दिया गया है। ठीक है?
तो अलर्ट सीक्वेंस क्या है यहां पे?
सस्िशियस लॉगिन जो होता है यूजर लैपटॉप पे
पहले तो वो होता है सस्पिशियस लॉगिन।
मिमीड्स को एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है जो कि
एक शानदार टूल है। एडमिन क्रेडेंशियल्स को
डंप किया जाता है। एक लास्ट में आज के
सेशन में एक टास्क भी है आपके लिए जो आपको
रियल टाइम उसी टाइम सॉल्व करने हैं। देख
मैं देखूंगा कि कितने लोग सॉल्व कर पाते
हैं उसको। मतलब आई विल सी राइट
एडमिन क्रेडेंशियल्स को डंप किया जाता है।
अटैकर लॉग्स जो है अटैकर जो है लॉग्स इंटू
फाइल सर्वर। अरेकर जो है फाइल सर्वर में
फिर वहां पे घुसता है एंड देन रैंसमवेयर
जो है वो डिप्लॉय कर हो जाती है। तो देयर
आर अलर्ट सीक्वेंसेस कुछ इस तरीके से
सीक्वेंस होती हैं जो यहां पे आपका चौथा
है अटैकर लॉग्स इंटू द फाइल सर्वर। फाइल
सर्वर में जब एंट्री लेता है तो बेसिकली
एक लेटरल मूवमेंट का पार्ट होता है। लैटरल
मूवमेंट की वहां पे एक प्रोसेस हो रही
होती है। ठीक है? यही प्रोसेस है। तो
सस्पेस लॉग इन होता है। मिमिक्स जो टूल है
उसको एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया जाता है टू अह अह
टू अह गेट एक्सेस इंटू दैट लैपटॉप बाय
क्रैकिंग और बेसिकली यू कैन से बाय अ
क्रैकिंग द पासवर्ड और बाय अ और बाय किस
चीज के पासवर्ड को चुरा के मेमोरी से चुरा
लिया एंड उस पासवर्ड को यूज़ करके लॉग इन
कर लिया। पासवर्डस लॉग इन बिना पासवर्ड के
लॉगिन कर लिया। ऐसा करके एंड एडमिन
क्रेडेंशियल्स को डंप कर दिया भैया ने एंड
अटैकर फाइल फाइल सर्वर में घुस गया एंड एन
सर्वर को डिप्लॉय कर दिया। दिस इज द लेटरल
मूवमेंट पार्ट द फाइल सर्वर पार्ट। ठीक
है? चलिए
अब नेक्स्ट जब हम चलते हैं तब हम आते हैं
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस पे। ये हमारा टोटल
जो था लेटरल मूवमेंट का पार्ट था। जहां पे
हमने लैटरल मूवमेंट के बारे में देखा। अब
हम यहां पे आते हैं हमारे एक और
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस को
लेके। अब देखो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन जो है
वो अपने आप में एक बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक
है एंड साइबर सिक्योरिटी का भी बहुत एक अ
बहुत एक मेजर टॉपिक माना जाता है फॉर
डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ सर्टिफिकेशंस बट यहां पे
एज अ एसओसी एल वन यू डोंट नीड टू गो डीप
डाइव इंटू इट बट यू हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड द
बेसिक्स एंड द कॉनंसेप्ट्स ऑफ इट एंड यू
हैव टू एक्सप्लोर बाय योरसेल्फ आल्सो जब
आप इस क्लास के बाद जाएंगे तो वीडियो को
दोबारा देखा करें रिकॉर्डिंग को दोबारा
देखें एक्सप्लोर करें खुद से भी पॉइंट्स
बनाना है Lindin पे डालना है टैग करना है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स को एंड 200 कमेंट्स पूरे पूरे
करने हैं। ये आपका टास्क होता है हमेशा।
इस आज के सेशन में वैसे लास्ट में मैं एक
लाइव टास्क कराऊंगा। मैं आपको टास्क
दूंगा। मैं देखूंगा कितने लोग सही बता पा
रहे हैं, क्या कर पा रहे हैं। प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन इज़ व्हेन एन अटैकर गेंस हायर
परमिशंस देन ओरिजिनली अलाउड। एग्जांपल
यूजर अकाउंट से एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एक्सेस।
सिंपल सा फंडा है कि एक अटैकर अगर नॉर्मल
यूजर से एक रूट यूजर बन जाता है या एक्सेस
ले लेता है रूट यूजर तक का या एक नॉर्मल
यूजर से एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर की तरफ अह
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर का एक्सेस पा लेता है
तो उस केस में वो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
कहलाता है। बस प्रिविलेज को एस्केलेट करना
इसी से समझना है कि आप एक लोअर लेवल के
बंदे हैं। अभी फिलहाल एक लोअर लेवल के
एंप्लई हैं। आप एक हायर लेवल पे हायर लेवल
के एंप्लई जो हैं वो बन जाते हैं। दोनों
में डिफरेंस है। अब नॉर्मल एक सेल्स का
बंदा है। सेल्स मार्केटिंग का बंदा है और
वो सीईओ बन जाता है। तो कि प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेट हो गई ना। सेल्स बंदे को सब
चीजों की प्रिविलेज नहीं होगी। सीईओ को हर
चीज का प्रिविलेज होगा। दैट्स द व्हाट
एक्चुअली वांट्स द अटैकर टू एस्केलेट द
प्रिविलेज टू गेट द हायर प्रिविलेज एंड टू
एक्सेस मोर एरियाज व्हिच दे आर नॉट अलाउड
ऑफ राइट पहला जीरो सबसे पहला स्टेप क्या
होता है प्री इंगेजमेंट मतलब जो भी आपका
टारगेट है उससे इंगेजमेंट प्री इंगेजमेंट
प्री इंगेजमेंट असेसमेंट्स जो होते हैं
मतलब रिकॉन से पहले का तैयारी जो है पूरी
तैयारी करना दूसरा स्टेप जो होता है यानी
कि ज़ीरो पहले जीरो स्टेप पे प्री
इंगेजमेंट आ गया फर्स्ट स्टेप होता है
रिकॉन करना जिसमें कि पहले पैसिव रिकॉन पे
अह फोकस किया जाता है। पैसिव रिकॉन का
मतलब होता है बिना इंटरेक्शन।
टारगेट से आप डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्टेड नहीं
है। टारगेट से आप डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्ट
नहीं कर रहे हैं। एंड यू आर गोइंग टू
स्टार्ट द रिकॉन यानी इनफेशन गैदरिंग
प्रोसेस। दूसरा जब डायरेक्टली इंटरेक्ट
करके बहुत इनफो नहीं मिल पाती है तो
इंटरेक्ट करना पड़ता है थोड़ा सा
डायरेक्टली तो उसको एक्टिव रिकॉन कहा जाता
है। तो ये स्टेप टू में होता है। स्टेप
थ्री में सर्विस की इनमरेशन होती है। जब
आप सिस्टम अह को इनमरेट करके देखते हैं कि
कौन-कौन सी सर्विसेस बेसिकली चल रही है इस
पे। जैसे कि अ दैट यू कैन अंडरस्टैंड कि
स्कैनिंग वगैरह जो पार्ट है उसी का है
स्कैनिंग इन न्यूमरेशन जहां पे आप
सिस्टम्स के पोर्ट्स को स्कैन करते हैं,
सर्विसेस को स्कैन करते हैं। देखते हैं कि
कौन सी सर्विज चल रही हैं? कौन सी सर्विज
की क्या वर्जनंस हैं? उन वर्जनंस में कोई
एक्सप्लइट उसका एक्सप्लइट या कोई वनरेबल
वर्जन है क्या? जैसे अगर किसी सिस्टम पे
एफटीपी की सर्विस चल रही है, एसएसएच की
सर्विस चल रही है या टेलनेट की सर्विस चल
रही है या आई मैप की चल कुछ भी चल रही है
तो वो कौन से वर्जन की चल रही है और वो
वर्जन वनरेबल था क्या कभी या उसका कोई
एक्सप्लइट मार्केट में अवेलेबल है अगर है
तो उसको एक्सप्लइट करके ट्राई करेंगे उसको
ब्रेकडाउन करने का उसके अंदर उसकी मदद से
सिस्टम में घुसने का उसके बाद स्टेप फोर
में एक्सप्लॉयटेशन का आ जाता है वो
एक्सप्लॉयट करके घुसने का और लास्ट में
एक्सप्लइट जब हो गया है तो एक अगर आप
नॉर्मल यूजर का एक्सेस मिला है आपको या
जेरिक यूजर का तो तो आप ट्राई करेंगे कि
उसको प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन के थ्रू आप एक
प्रिविलेज यूजर बन जाए। यानी कि एक
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर या रूट यूजर बन जाए। बस
सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो ये पूरा का पूरा
स्टेप होता है प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन में।
यहीं से आपका प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन पूरा
कंप्लीट समझ में आ गया होगा। आर यू आर यू
गेटिंग गाइस? समझ में आया आपको यहां से
प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन की कहानी? आर यू
गेटिंग बताइए।
प्लीज टेल मी सभी को समझ में आ गया?
अ गर्ल्स थिंक थैंक यू सर सो मच सर इतना
डेप्थ में समझाने के लिए ऐसे डिटेल कंटेंट
मुझे कहीं नहीं मिला। यू आर मोर देन
वेलकम। आई थिंक कि
मुझे थैंक यू बोलना चाहिए। आई आप लोगों को
कि आप लोग टाइम निकाल के आते हैं यहां पे।
एंड अपना टाइम देते हैं प्रिशियस टाइम और
समझते हैं आप।
सो थैंक्स फॉर दैट टू एवरीबॉडी।
सर मैं सीधा पांच क्लास से लाइव देख रहा
हूं। कोई बात नहीं आप प्रीवियस क्लासेस को
कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा। कोई दिक्कत नहीं।
थैंक्स बिकॉज़ आई डोंट वांट टू इन्वेस्ट
माय मनी इन दैट कोर्स। और डीएच द प्रॉफिट
इज़ आई एम एक्चुअ आई एम एक्चुअली आई हैव
YouTube चैनल अ
ओके बॉबी आपका YouTube चैनल कौन सा है बता
दीजिए एक बार एक बार वो भी बताइए ताकि पता
चले
कोई बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं गर्ल्स
या गॉट इट चलिए सभी लोगों को यू आर वेलकम
गौरव गौरव यू आर वेलकम एकदम क्लियर यू आर
ग्रेट थैंक्स
ट्रेनिंग कितने लेक्चर में एंड नहीं होगी
तीन से चार महीने की मैंने टाइमिंग बोली
थी
या
बहुत अच्छी बात है।
यू आर प्रोवाइडिंग गुड कंटेंट फॉर अस।
थैंक यू। यू आर वेलकम। आई होप कि आपको ऐसे
अच्छा लगे लगता रहेगा। ऐसे ही अच्छे
कंटेंट्स आते रहेंगे।
बग बाउंड्री और एथिकल हैकिंग दोनों को
कंपैरेली आप कर लीजिए अगर आपके पास टाइम
मैनेज हो पा रहा है तो। ठीक है? तो ये
प्रिविलज एस्क्लेशन। अब हम प्रिविलेज
एस्कलेशंस के टाइप्स को थोड़ा सा देखते
हैं। उसको समझने की कोशिश करते हैं। ठीक
है? उसके पहले प्रिविल एस्केलेशन के
टाइप्स को देखते हैं और उसको समझने की
कोशिश करते हैं।
हम
या वेलकम
ओके तो प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस के जनरली इधर
अब ध्यान दे देना है सभी को। सभी लोग इधर
ध्यान दीजिए एंड कम कम हियर एंड फोकस ऑन
दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग। प्रिविलेज एस्कलेशन
के टू टाइप्स होते हैं। ठीक है? एक होता
है वर्टिकल प्रिविलज एस्क्लेशन और एक होता
है हॉरिजॉन्टल प्रिविलज्लेशन। वर्टिकल का
मतलब कुछ इस तरीके से हो गया आपका सीधा
ऐसे और हॉरिजॉन्टल का मतलब होता है एक
लेवल के अंदर में। तो हॉरिजॉन्टल वर्टिकल
में सीधा-सीधा मतलब है वर्टिकल में एक
हायरार्की होती है। एक हायरार्की होगी।
ऊपर से नीचे नीचे से ऊपर और हॉरिजॉन्टल
में क्या होगा? एक फ्लैट सरफेस होगा। एक
फ्लैट जो होगा उसी पे सब कुछ होगा। वहीं
पे अ जो है इसका मतलब सिंपल समझना है कि
एक रूम में चारप टेबल्स आर चारप चेयर लगे
हैं। एक टेबल के चारों तरफ वो हॉरिजॉन्टल
लेआउट को दिखाता है और एक टेबल उसके ऊपर
दूसरा टेबल उसके ऊपर तीसरा टेबल ऐसे करके
वो हॉरिजॉन्ट जो वर्टिकल लेआउट है उसको
दिखाता है। ठीक है? सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो
वर्टिकल प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन में क्या होता
है? यूजर से एडमिन की तरफ जाया जाता है।
ठीक है? इस प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन में जो
अटैकर है एक यूजर से एडमिन में एस्केलेट
होता है खुद को। तो नॉर्मल यूजर होते हैं।
फिर लोकल एडमिन जो होते हैं और फिर डोमेन
एडमिन अगर किसी हम एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी की
बात करें या नेटवर्क की बात करें उसमें।
अदरवाइज़ लोकल कंप्यूटर के लिए यही दो
स्टेप्स होते हैं। नॉर्मल यूज़र से लोकल
एडमिन। बस सिंपल सा फंडा है। तो ये होता
है आपका वर्टिकल प्रिविलेज एस्कलेशन। अब
देखो
ओके। हॉरिजॉन्टल प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन में
क्या होता है? यूज़र्स से अनदर यूजर में
जाया जाता है। जैसे मैंने बोला कि एक टेबल
के चारों तरफ चेयर्स हैं। उस चेयर पे
अलग-अलग यूज़र्स बैठे हैं। तो एक यूजर से
दूसरे यूजर में। उसमें क्या होगा? एंप्लई
अकाउंट से मैनेजर अकाउंट सेम लेवल बट
डिफरेंट प्रिविलेज।
इसमें ये दोनों यूज़र्स ही हैं। बट क्या है
कि एक एंप्लई अकाउंट है और एक मैनेजर का
अकाउंट है। तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है एंप्लई
अकाउंट से ज्यादा प्रिविलेज्ड होगा मैनेजर
का अकाउंट एंड उससे आप ज्यादा चीजें कर
सकते हैं। ये दो दोनों आपके टाइप्स होते
हैं। राइट?
अब मैं आपको इसको थोड़ा और विजुअलाइज़ करके
बताता हूं। तो हम हॉरिजॉन्टल
प्रिविलज्लेशन अटैक यहां देख रहे हैं एंड
वर्टिकल प्रिविलज एस्क्लेशन अटैक देख रहे
हैं। अब हॉरिजॉन्टल में क्या है? देखो
यहां पे हॉरिजॉन्टल में एक एंप्लई एक
सेल्स रिप्रेजेंटेटिव है। एक बिज़नेस
एनालिस्ट है, एक डायरेक्टर ऑफ़ मार्केटिंग
है, एक मार्केटिंग मैनेजर है। ये सब एक
लेवल पे काम कर रहे हैं। तो क्या है? एन
इंटरनल हॉरिजॉन्टल एस्केलेशन अटैक कैन अकर
बिटवीन ईच ऑफ़ दीज़ अकाउंट्स। यह सारे
अकाउंट्स में हॉरिजॉन्टल अटैक जो है वह
प्रिव एस्क्लेशन अटैक जो है पॉसिबल है। हो
सकता है। अटैकर्स कैन आल्सो अचीव
हॉरिजॉन्टल एस्क्लेशन ब इनिशियली
कॉम्प्रोमाइजिंग वन ऑफ़ दीज़ अकाउंट्स। एक
अकाउंट को कॉम्प्रोमाइज़ करके पाइवोटिंग
एंड लैटरल पाइवोटिंग के थ्रू लैटरल
मूवमेंट करते हुए दूसरे अकाउंट को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर सकता है। पॉसिबल है। तो
ये होता है आपका हॉरिजॉन्टल। वर्टिकल में
क्या हो जाता है कि एक नॉर्मल स्टैंडर्ड
यूजर है। फिर इन थोड़ा और प्रिविलेज बढ़ा
आईटी हेल्प डेस्क जो रिप्रेजेंटेटिव है
एंड देन सिस्टम एडमिन जो है वो है। तो इस
तरीके से वर्टिकली जो है उसका प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेट होता है। अ थ्रेट एक्टर मूव्स
फ्रॉम स्टैंडर्ड यूजर एक्सेस टू एन आईटी
हेल्प डिस्क अकाउंट बिफोर गेनिंग द रूट
एक्सेस और द मेन सिस्टम एडमिन एक्सेस। ईच
सब्सकुएंट स्टेप रिप्रेजेंट्स मोर
प्रिविलेज एक्सेस। तो ये एक-एक स्टेप पे
डिफरेंट प्रिविलेज जो होते हैं और एक
पिछले वाले से ज्यादा प्रिविलजेस के होते
हैं। ये होता है आपका वर्टिकल प्रिविलेज
एस्क्लेशन। ये बहुत सिंपल सा फंडा था। आई
होप आपको समझ में आया होगा। अब यहां पे
व्हाई अटैकर्स नीड प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन?
जैसे कि अटैकर को क्यों अह जरूरी थी?
लेटरल मूवमेंट की हमने समझा था। वैसे ही
प्रिविलज एक्केलेशन की क्यों जरूरत है तो
बहुत सिंपल सा बहुत सिंपल सा कांसेप्ट है
बिकॉज़ इनिशियल कॉम्प्रोमाइज ऑफेन गिव्स
हमेशा जो इमिनिशियल कॉम्प्रोमाइज होता है
वो क्या जब अटैकर पहली बार कॉम्प्रोमाइज
करता है कोई सिस्टम को या कोई डिवाइसेस को
तो पहला इंप्रेशन लो प्रिविलज एक्सेस का
होता है कि प्रिविलज एक्सेस थोड़ी कम होती
है उसको बट अटैकर क्या वांट क्या चाहता है
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर एक्सेस हो जाए या रूट
एक्सेस हो जाए या डोमेन का एडमिन बन जाए
यानी एक पूरे नेटवर्क के अंदर जितने भी
सिस्टम्स हैं उन सबका एक एडमिन बन जाए
राइट व्हिच अलाउस देम टू डिसेबल
सिक्योरिटी टूल्स, डंप क्रेडेंशियल्स,
एक्सेस सर्वर्स, डिप्लॉयर एंड समवेयर। तो,
यह जब प्रिविलज़ एस्केलेशन कर लेता है
अटैकर, तो सिक्योरिटी टूल्स को डिसेबल कर
सकता है। अब मैं एडमिन हूं, तो मैं
Windows डिफेंडर के सिक्योरिटी को डिसेबल
कर सकता हूं। क्रेडेंशियल्स को मैं ईज़ली
डंप कर सकता हूं। जो भी क्रेडेंशियल्स
हैं, उनके हैशेस हैं, उनको मैं डंप कर
सकता हूं। मिड जैसे टूल्स का यूज़ कर सकता
हूं। ईज़ली डंपिंग हो जाएगी। सर्वर्स को
मैं आराम से एक्सेस कर सकता हूं।
रैंसमवेयर को डिप्लॉय कर सकता हूं।
क्योंकि मैं एडमिन हूं। मैं सब कुछ हूं।
मैं ही सर्वे सर्वा हूं। मैं सर्वत्र हूं
एंड मैं सर्वज्ञ हूं। तो होता है ना कि हर
जगह पे हूं। हर कुछ जानता हूं और मैं ही
सब कुछ हूं। तो यही है आपका एडमिन अकाउंट।
बस यही चीज है। जैसे कि भागवत गीता में
श्री कृष्ण बोलते हैं क्या बोलते हैं? कि
मैं ही सब कुछ हूं। मैं ही सर्वत्र हूं।
मैं ही सर्वज्ञ हूं। मैं सब कुछ जानता
हूं।
तो वही हमारा एडमिन होता है। वही हमारा
रूट होता है। सब कुछ होता है। एक बार
एक्सेस मिल गया पूरा सिस्टम आपके हाथ में
है। राइट? सो दैट्स व्हाई अटैकर वांट्स टू
डू द प्रिविलेज एस्क्लेशन। आई होप आपको
समझ में आ गया होगा।
ठीक है? आपको समझ में आ गया? मैंने
डिफरेंस बताया था शुभम। आई थिंक आप थोड़ा
लेट आए थे। आप प्लीज रिकॉर्डिंग देखिएगा
एक बार। स्टार्टिंग में ही किसी ने पूछा
था तो मैंने बताया भी था।
बट स्टिल ठीक है। चलिए कॉमन प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन टेक्निक्स में बेसिकली हमने जब
लैटरल मूवमेंट के टेक्निक्स देखे थे तो हम
प्रिविलेज एस्कलेशन टेक्निक्स भी हैं कुछ
जो हम अभी देखेंगे जिसमें कि एक
एक्सप्लइटिंग सॉफ्टवेयर अवेलेबिलिटीज़ आता
है। क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग आता है।
मिसकॉन्फ़िगर परमिशंस आते हैं। टोकन
इंपर्सनेशन आता है। शेड्यूल टास्क अब्यूज
आता है। ये कॉमन प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस के
टेक्निक्स हैं। अब समझते हैं इनमें
क्या-क्या होता है। लेट्स अंडरस्टैंड दिस।
एक्सप्लइटिंग सॉफ्टवेयर वनेबिलिटीज। ये
बहुत कॉमन सा टेक्निक है जिसमें कि आप
सॉफ्टवेयर की वनेबिलिटीज को एक्सप्लइट
करते हैं। सॉफ्टवेयर की वनेबिलिटीज़ कोई सी
भी वनेबिलिटी से कोई सॉफ्टवेयर वनरेबल है
उसका एक्सप्लइट खोजा आपने एक्सप्लइट आपको
मिला उससे उसको एक्सप्लइट करते हैं और
एक्सेस ले लेते हैं। एग्जांपल आउटडेटेड
Windows कर्नल। Windows का कर्नल, Windows
का अह कोई सॉफ्टवेयर या कोई प्रोग्राम या
वर्जन या फ़वेयर आउटडेटेड है तो उसको
एक्सप्लइट किया जा सकता है। या कोई
ड्राइवर्स हैं उनके सॉफ्टवेयर्स वनेरेबल
हैं या आउटडेटेड हैं तो वनरेबल हैं तो
उनको एक्सप्लइट किया जा सकता है। अटैकर
रंस एक्सप्लइट बिकम्स एडमिन। अटैकर उस केस
में क्या करता है? उस पर्टिकुलर वनरेबल
सर्विज की एक्सप्लइट को रन करता है एंड
वहां पे वो एडमिन बन जाता है। एमएसएफ
कंसोल या मेटा एक्स्प्लइट इसका नाम आप
लोगों ने सुना है किसी ने?
हैव यू हर्ड अबाउट एमएसएफ कंसोल और
मेटास्टइड? आप में से कितने लोग जानते
हैं?
ओके काफी लोग जानते हैं। तो मेटा
एक्सप्लइट में जिन लोगों ने अगर यूज़ किया
होगा तो उनको पता है कि आप उसमें
एक्सप्लइट्स रन करते हैं एंड आपसे आप वहां
पे प्रिविलेज एस्क्लेशंस भी करते हैं।
राइट? अगर आपने डीईएचई की हमारी सीरीज
देखी होगी तो उसमें भी शायद आपको कहीं ना
कहीं मिला होगा। डेफ्रोनिक्स के देखो
डेफ्रोनिक्स के YouTube चैनल पे जितने भी
वीडियोस हैं प्लेलिस्ट पे जाएंगे तो जितने
भी कोर्सर्सेस एंड वीडियोस हैं अगर आपने
सारे वीडियोस और कोर्सर्सेस देख लिए तो
आपको हर चीज का आईडिया लग जाएगा आप अनजान
बिल्कुल नहीं रहेंगे कि सर ये क्या होता
है? वो क्या होता है? हर टॉपिक को लगभग हर
तरीके से डील कर ही दी गया है। कुछ
टॉपिक्स जो बग बाउंटज में हैं वो तो पूरी
डिटेल आपको दी गई है। कुछ टॉपिक्स आपको
मान लो कि अह नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी में नहीं
पढ़ाई गई है तो डीएई में कवर हो गई हैं।
डीएई में नहीं है तो नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
में होंगी। ओसंट वाले में होंगी। Python
हर चीज़ में हर चीज़ घुसाया हुआ है। तो आपको
वो चीज़ देखनी चाहिए। हर एक वीडियोस को
एक्सप्लोर करना चाहिए। देखना चाहिए। मैं
यही बोलूंगा। उसके बाद आती है
क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग। कडेंशियल को डंप
करना। तो मिमीज जो टूल जैसे टूल्स हैं
उनका यूज़ करते हैं। एल्स एस मेमोरी डंपिंग
की जाती है बेसिकली। अ एंड उस एल्स एस
मेमोरी डंपिंग का बेसिकली यूज करके एंड
वहां से क्या चुराया जाता है? वहां से
आपका पासवर्ड हैश जो है वो चुरा लिया जाता
है। ठीक है? एल्स एस काफी इंपॉर्टेंट एक
फैक्टर होता है। अगर आप में से कई लोगों
को शायद इसके बारे में नहीं पता होगा। बट
जो लोग मेरे स्टूडेंट रहे हुए हैं या
होंगे अ लाइक जिन्होंने एथिकल हैकिंग की
कोर्स वगैरह करी होगी तो उनको एल्स के
बारे में पता है जो लोकल सिक्योरिटी
अथॉरिटी होती है अ वो उनके बारे में पता
होगा ऑलरेडी कि वो किस तरीके से काम करती
है कैसे पासवर्ड लॉगिन को ये सपोर्ट करती
है एलsस किस तरीके से रिस्पांसिबल होती है
लॉगिनस के लिए जो आप लॉगिन करते हैं विंडज़
के अंदर में तो वहां से मेमोरी डंपिंग
करके एंड ये क्या करते हैं भैया हमारे
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग में हेल्प ली जाती है
मेमिकार्ड जैसे टूल का यूज़ करके तो एडमिन
पासवर्ड्स को एक्सट्रैक्ट किया जाता है।
एसओसी के अंदर क्या इंडिकेटर आएगा? एल्स
एस प्रोसेस एक्सेस एल्स को किसी ने एक्सेस
किया है। क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग अलर्ट्स
क्रेडेंशियल्स को डंप किया गया है। एल्स
ही वो प्रोसेस है जिसमें जिसकी हेल्प से
आप लॉग इन कर पाते हैं Windows के अंदर
में। एंड वही रिस्पांसिबल है Windows के
लॉग इन एक्टिविटी के लिए मेनली। ठीक है?
क्योंकि उसके बिना आप लॉग इन नहीं कर
सकते। अगर एल्स कंप्रोमाइज हो गया तो
Windows का लॉग इन जो है कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो
जाएगा। सो यहां पे स्पैम मत कीजिए आप।
इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट। सर जी मैंने पास अ मेरे
सर जी मेरे पास नेटवर्किंग की एक बुक है
फॉर एसओसी एनालिस्ट के लिए मैं आपको सेंड
कर देता हूं अगर आप चाहिए तो ग्रुप में
हां कर दो कर दो कोई बात नहीं है कर दो इफ
यू कैन आराम से आप हमारे WhatsApp पे भी
कर सकते हो कोई दिक्कत नहीं बट प्लीज आप
रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप
वो मत कीजिए स्पैम मत कीजिए
हां बिल्कुल
सर मुझे आईटी सपोर्ट में 2 ईयर
एक्सपीरियंस हो गया है। पर अब मुझे जॉब
रोल चेंज करना है। रेड टीम पर डायरेक्ट
रेड टीम पर मुश्किल है। इसलिए मैं ऐसा हां
बिल्कुल आप एसओसी के थ्रू जाइए। बिल्कुल
सही है। बिल्कुल सही स्टेप है आपका। कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। आप रेड टीमिंग में भी
जा सकते हैं। नो नॉट एन इशू। हां। अब आते
हैं हमारे नेक्स्ट टेक्निक प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन के। इसको हम बोलते हैं
मिसक़िगरर्ड परमिशंस। मिसकॉन्फिगरर्ड
परमिशंस। ऐसी परमिशन जो मिसकॉन्फिगरर्ड की
मिसकॉन्फिगरर्ड है मिसकॉन्फ़िगरेशंस हुए
हैं उसमें उसके थ्रू अटैक करना। सर्विस
रंस एज सिस्टम बट एग्जीक्यूटेबल इज़
राइटेबल। मतलब ऐसे सर्विस जो कि सिस्टम की
तरह रन हो रहा है। बट एग्जीक्यूटेबल जो है
वो राइटेबल है। राइटेबल है। राइटेबल
परमिशन के साथ है। अटैकर रिप्लेसेस फाइल्स
गेन एडमिन एक्सेस। अब अटैकर क्या करेगा?
उस सिस्टम फाइल को रिप्लेस कर देगा और
उसको एडमिन एक्सेस मिल जाएगा। क्योंकि वो
एक राइटेबल एग्जीक्यूटेबल है। मतलब
राइटेबल है। उसमें राइट भी गया है। तो
हमेशा यूजुअली रीडेबल होनी चाहिए। ओनली
रीड ओनली होनी चाहिए ज्यादातर। बट अगर
राइट ओनली परमिशंस के साथ वो है ऐसी कोई
सेंसिटिव फाइल तो अटैकर उस फाइल को
रिप्लेस कर सकता है। क्योंकि उसके पास
ऑलरेडी राइट ओनली परमिशन तो वो कुछ भी
चेंजेस कर सकता है और उसके पास कंप्लीट जो
है वो एक्सेस हो जाएगा। क्योंकि ऑलरेडी वो
फाइल जो है वो क्या है? राइट ओनली फाइल है
तो ऑब्वियस सी बात है उसके पास परमिशन
ज्यादा है। तो रीड ओनली फाइल्स ज्यादा
अच्छा होते हैं। हमेशा कोई भी इंपॉर्टेंट
चीज है तो उसकी परमिशन रीड ओनली करके
ज्यादा रखना ज्यादा बेटर है। राइट
एग्जीक्यूट का परमिशन ना ही दो तो इट्स
बेटर। टोकन इंपर्सनेशन विंडज़ एक्सेस टोकंस
स्टोलन फ्रॉम हाई प्रिविलेज प्रोसेससेस।
अटैकर इंपर्सनेट्स एडमिन। अब कोई एडमिन
अकाउंट या रूट अकाउंट या कोई भी हाई
प्रिविलेज अकाउंट्स है तो उनके टोकन को
चुरा लेना। और चुराने के बाद अटैकर
इंपोर्सनेट करता है कि वही एडमिन है।
अटैकर अपने को ऐसा दिखाता है कि मैं ही
एडमिन हूं भाई। मैं ही सब कुछ हूं। मैं ही
सर्वत्र हूं। मैं ही सर्वज्ञ हूं। मैं ही
सर्वशक्तिमान हूं। एंड वही करके वो टोकन
इंपोशनेशन करके अटैक कर लेता है। शेड्यूल
टास्क अब्यूज अटैकर मॉडिफाइड मॉडिफाइज़ द
शेड्यूल टास्क रनिंग एज एडमिन। ऐसे-ऐसे
टास्क जो ऐज़ अ एडमिन रन हो रहे हैं।
शेड्यूल्ड टास्क हैं। उन शेड्यूल टास्क को
चेंज कर देना। मतलब उस शेड्यूल टास्क के
अंदर में इंजेक्ट कर देना। मलेशियस टास्क
को इंजेक्ट करना। ऐसे टास्क जो नहीं
एग्जीक्यूट होने चाहिए उनको वहां पे
एग्जीक्यूट कराना शेड्यूल टास्क के थ्रू।
ये भी जो है एक टेक्निक होते हैं
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन के अंदर में। तो ये
सारे कुछ अलग-अलग डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट टेक्निक
है। बट इन सब टेक्निक के बाद इन सब
टेक्निक के अलावा आपको समझना क्या है?
आपको समझना है बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स। आपको
समझना है
कोर कांसेप्ट्स कि प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस
होते क्या एक्सैक्टली
गोली मारो टाइप्स को ये चीजें टाइप्स की
जानकारी और नॉलेज होनी आपके लिए बस तभी के
लिए इंपॉर्टेंट है जब आप इंटरव्यू वगैरह
के लिए दे आते हैं। इंटरव्यू में बोलना
पड़ता है। पूछ देगा भाई अब इंटरव्यूअर
देखो इंटरव्यूअर बैठा है सामने। अब
इंटरव्यूअर का दिमाग खसका हुआ हो सकता है।
इंटरव्यूअर पागल हो सकता है। वो कुछ भी
पूछ सकता है। इंटरव्यूअर का तो माइंड के
मूड के ऊपर है ना अपने। सोचते-सचते रहेगा।
कुछ भी पूछ देगा। तो उसके लिए तो प्रिपेयर
हो के जाना होगा। अब आप आंसर नहीं करोगे
तो बैड इंप्रेशन उसको लगेगा अरे नहीं आता
भैया आपको तो ऐसे दिमाग का लेकिन अगर आप
उसके हर आंसर क्वेश्चन का आंसर कर दोगे तो
वो सोचेगा कि अरे यार ये तो सारा आंसर कर
रहा है। अब क्या करूं मैं क्या करूं? आउट
ऑफ क्वेश्चन हो जाएगा बेचारा। इंटरव्यूअर
भी प्रिपयर्ड हो के ही आता है। अगर जब तक
बहुत नॉलेजेबल इंटरव्यूअर कोई ना हो। कोई
एक्स्ट्राऑर्डिनरी इंटरव्यूअर ना हो तब तक
थोड़ा एवरेज है। तो उस समय के लिए आप
तैयारी कीजिए। बाकी कांसेप्ट्स को एंड कोर
जो इसका अह नॉलेज है कोर जो आपकी
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन है उसको समझने की कोशिश
कीजिए कि प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन एक्चुअली
क्या होता है बस हो गया इससे ज्यादा आप
ऑटोमेटिकली सब कुछ हैंडल कर लेंगे अब देखो
हां एसओसी जबजब जबजब गया तब-तब पागल मिला
हां इंटरव्यूअर्स थोड़े से होते ही ऐसे
हैं क्या कर सकते हो एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स ऑफ
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशंस में अलग-अलग एसोस इंडिकेटर्स
होते हैं। क्या होते हैं? किस टाइप के
एसओसी इंडिकेटर्स होते हैं? सडन एडमिन
राइट्स असाइनमेंट।
ऐसा होने लगेगा सडन कि एडमिन राइट्स असाइन
होने लग रहे हैं। न्यू एडमिन अकाउंट्स
क्रिएट होने लग रहे हैं। सर्विस क्रिएट्स
होने लग रहे हैं। इवेंट्स में अलग-अलग
डिफरेंट अलग-अलग सस्िशियस एल्स एस एक्सेस
होने लग रहा है। प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
एक्सप्लइट्स यूज़ होने लग रहे हैं। ऐसे-से
एलर्स जो हैं
आपको एज एसओसी देखने को
मिल जाएगा। ठीक है
सर। सर एसओसी में स्क्रिप्टिंग आनी जरूरी
है। देखो एआई का जमाना है। ऐसी कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट है नहीं। एआई की एआई की
नॉलेज थोड़ी इंपॉर्टेंट है। बाकी आप
स्क्रिप्टिंग और जो भी जरूरत होगी आप खुद
ही कर लोगे। एआई की अगर आपको नॉलेज है एआई
को यूज़ करना आता है। प्र्प अच्छे से आती
है प्र्प्ट को यूज़ करना। प्र्ट
देना तो आप ये सब आराम से कर लोगे। उसके
लिए इतना टेंशन नहीं लेना है। फिलहाल कोर
कांसेप्ट भी आपको आपके लिए बहुत है। अब
कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट विंडोज इवेंट्स आईडीज हैं
वो मैं आपको डिस्कस कर देता हूं। जैसे एक
इवेंट आईडी होती है 46 72। ये किसके लिए
होती है? इसका मतलब क्या होता है? स्पेशल
प्रिविलेजेस जो हैं असाइन हुए हैं। तो जब
भी ऐसा कोई इवेंट आईडी आता है अह आपके
एसओसी अह ट्रिगर में तो समझिए कि कोई
स्पेशल प्रिविलेज असाइन किया गया है। 468
प्रोसेस कोई क्रिएट जो है वो हुई है। 4720
यूजर अकाउंट क्रिएट हुआ है। 4732 यूजर ऐड
किया गया है एडमिन ग्रुप में। यानी कि एक
एडमिन ग्रुप होगा जहां पे जितने भी यूज़र्स
होंगे सबको एक लेवल का परमिशन जो है वो
फिक्स लेवल का परमिशन वो हो सकता है सारे
लेवल की परमिशन टोटल परमिशन जो है वो मिल
जाए। तो वो एक ग्रुप में ऐड किया जा रहा
है। तो ये सारी चीजें बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग
चीज है। ठीक है ये सारी चीजें इंपॉर्टेंट
है। सर आप एआई का यूज़ सिखाओगे? बिल्कुल
एआई का यूज़ सिखाएंगे बिना उसके तो आज के
टाइम में बहुत मुश्किल है।
तो यस आई विल इंटीग्रेट दैट आई विल
इंटीग्रेट द एi पार्ट आल्सो। सो यू डोंट
हैव टू वरी अबाउट दैट। मैंने बोला है ना
कि जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग है, जॉब रेडी कोर्स
है तो मैं सब इंटीग्रेट करके पढ़ाऊंगा।
चाहे कुछ भी हो जाए। एआई का तो इंटीग्रेशन
बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है। उसके बिना आज
के टाइम में कुछ है ही नहीं। एंड जब आप
एसओसी के लिए जाएंगे भी तो एआई की नॉलेज
और एआई इंटीग्रेशन एआई कैसे आप लेंगे
हेल्प यूज़ करेंगे उसकी नॉलेज तो होनी ही
चाहिए। राइट?
क्या बात है। एआई की हेल्प से भग बंटी बग
फाइंड किया है। चलिए अच्छा बात है। हां
हां अलग-अलग कोड्स होते हैं। वेद पॉल यू
आर राइट। मैंने यहां पे कुछ कोड्स लिए
हैं।
ठीक है? हां। तो एक रियल रैंसमवेयर
सिनेरियो को हम देखते हैं। एक रियल
रैंसवेयर सिनेरियो। उसमें एग्जैक्टली क्या
अटैक चेन फॉलो होता है? किस तरह का एक
अटैक चेन फॉलो होता है? वो हम देखते हैं।
जब कोई रियल रसमवेयर अटैक होता है तो एक
फिशिंग ईमेल आती है। फिशिंग ईमेल से यूजर
का लैपटॉप कॉम्प्रोमाइज होता है क्योंकि
वो फिशिंग ईमेल में अटैचमेंट्स या
मेलेशियस फाइल्स पे क्लिक कर देता है।
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो गई। क्रेडेंशियल्स डंप कर
दिए जाते हैं। मिमिक जैसे टूल्स का यूज़
किया जाता है। क्रेडेंशियल्स डंपिंग की
जाती है। क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग करके
प्रिविलेज को एस्केलेट किया जाता है। उसके
बाद जैसे ही प्रिविज्लेट होती है तो लेटरल
मूवमेंट जो है शुरू हो जाती है। क्योंकि
एडमिन एक्सेस है। अब तो भाई कहीं से कहीं
घूम लेंगे। डोमेन कंट्रोलर का एक्सेस मिल
जाता है। एक डोमेन में है या एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी की बात करें एरसवेयर जो है वो
डिप्लॉय कर दिया जाता है। जितने भी मशीनंस
हैं
क्योंकि जितने भी मशीनंस है ना जितने भी
मशीनंस हैं तो बेसिकली सबका एक्सेस आ चुका
है। लैटरल मूवमेंट हो चुकी है। डोमेन
कंट्रोलर का एक्सेस आ चुका है। तो यू हैव
यू हैव एक्सेस टू ऑल द मशीनंस ऑन द
नेटवर्क। तो आप रैंसम वेयर डेप्लॉयमेंट का
काम जो है आराम से शुरू कर सकते हैं। ठीक
है? ये चीज़ है। अब मैं आपको दोनों के बीच
के डिफरेंस थोड़ा समझाता हूं। लेटरल
मूवमेंट और प्रिविलेज एक्सलेशन के बीच के
डिफरेंस समझाता हूं। यहां से आपका बहुत
कुछ क्लियर होगा। इसको ध्यान दीजिएगा थोड़ा
सा। ठीक है? प्लीज डोंट स्पैम गाइस। प्लीज
डोंट स्पैम। ठीक है?
इवेंट आईडीज आपको याद नहीं वैसे करनी है।
देखो, इवेंट आईडीज़ को याद नहीं करनी होती
है। जब आप प्रैक्टिस में आएंगे तो
ऑटोमेटिकली आपको याद हो जाएगा। बट वैसे
10-15 इवेंट आईडीज़ को आप याद कर लीजिए।
थोड़ा दिमाग में बिठा लीजिए। इट विल बी
बेटर। तो यहां पे डिफरेंस दोनों के बीच
लैटरल मूवमेंट और प्रिविलशन के बीच में
क्या है? मैं आपको बताता हूं। फीचर्स
फीचर्स में पहले आते हैं। पहला फीचर में
गोल। गोल क्या है? मूव अक्रॉस सिस्टम।
इसका मेन गोल है सिस्टम्स के अक्रॉस को
मूव करना है। अटैकर का मूव करना होता है।
प्रिविल एस्केलेशन में क्या करता है?
अटैकर हायर परमिशंस को गेन करता है।
डायरेक्शन ये एक साइडवे डायरेक्शन में
लेटरल मूवमेंट होती है। एंड ये जो
प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन होती है वो अपवर्ड
डायरेक्शन में होती है। लेटरल मूवमेंट इज़
अ साइडवेज डायरेक्शन। बट प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन इज़ ऑलवेज वन लोअर प्रिविलेज टू
हायर प्रिविलेज डायरेक्शन। एग्जांपल में
लैपटॉप से सर्वर की तरफ ये क्या हुआ? एक
लेटर मूवमेंट हो गई। बट यूजर से एडमिन की
तरफ जा रहे हैं तो ये प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
कहा जाएगा। समझ में आया? दोनों कितना
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज़ है। लैपटॉप से सर्वर पे
गए तो ये लेटर मूवमेंट हो गया। यूजर से
एडमिन पे गए ये प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन हो
गया। पर्पस क्या है? एक्सपैंड एक्सेस एंड
यहां पे पर्पस है प्लेज़ का कंट्रोल गेन
करना। मतलब यहां पे है कि मल्टीपल
डिवाइसेस में अपना एक्सेस जो है वो
एक्सपेंड करना है। एक से दूसरे दूसरे
तीसरे तीसरे चौथे ऐसे करके ऐसे करना है।
मैं यहां पे अ जस्ट अ सेकंड मैं यहां पे
इनको टाइम आउट कर देता हूं। स्पैम कर रहे
हैं तो थोड़ी देर टाइम आउट इनको कर देते
हैं।
ओके टाइम आउट हो गए हैं ये। काफी ज्यादा
स्पैम हो रहे थे। इट प्रोनाउंसेस रिक वेद
पॉल। ओके रिक विद पॉल थैंक्स फॉर लेटिंग
मी नो क्योंकि मुझे कंफ्यूजन हो ही रहा
था। तो यहां लेटरल मूवमेंट में आप मल्टीपल
डिवाइसेस पे एक्सपेंड करते हैं कि एक
डिवाइस को कंट्रोल किया कमांड किया दूसरे
डिवाइस पे जा रहे हैं, तीसरे डिवाइस पे जा
रहे हैं। ऐसे करके प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
में आप कंट्रोल गेन करते हैं। जैसे एक
डिवाइस में आपने गेन कर लिया एक्सेस। तो
अब उसी में प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट करके एक
नॉर्मल यूजर से एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर यूजर या
रूट यूजर की तरफ आप जाते हैं। तो ये मेजर
डिफरेंसेस हैं इन दोनों के बीच में। तो
दोनों बहुत डिफरेंट चीजें हैं। पैरेलल
लैटरल मूवमेंट इज़ अ डिफरेंट थिंग।
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन इज अ कंप्लीट डिफरेंट
थिंग। तो ये दोनों का मैंने इसलिए यहां पे
आपके लिए डाला था डिफरेंस ताकि आपको थोड़ा
क्लेरिटी मिल जाए दोनों के बीच की ताकि आप
ये ना सोचिए कि दोनों में कोई समानता कुछ
ऐसा है या कुछ ऐसा बोथ आर डिफरेंट। अच्छा
अब दिमाग में घुस रहा है। अच्छा अब दिमाग
में घुस रहा है। चलिए ठीक है। अच्छी बात
है। घुस रहा है तो। ये डिफरेंस समझ में आ
गया सबको?
यह आर यू गेटिंग
देखो आप शुभम आपको मैं देखो ये मैंने पहले
ही बात बता दी थी आप नहीं थे उस टाइम हो
सकता है लैटरल मूवमेंट में मैंने पहले ही
बोला साइडवेज होती है बट क्या होता है एक
लैपटॉप से एक सर्वर के तरफ जा रहे हैं
यहां हम प्रिविलेज नहीं खोज रहे हैं वी आर
नॉट सर्चिंग फॉर एनी काइंड ऑफ़ प्रिविलेज
कि हमें ज्यादा प्रिविलेज मिल जाए हमें
ज्यादा कंट्रोल मिल जाए ऐसा नहीं खोज रहे
बट प्रिविलेज एस्कलेशन में अगर हम
हॉरिजॉन्टल में भी जाते हैं तो हम एक
नॉर्मल एंप्लई से मैनेजर की तरफ जाते तो
हमें वहां प्रिविलेज खोज रहे हैं। हम वी
आर सर्चिंग फॉर प्रिविलेज कि एक नॉर्मल
एंप्लई को कम प्रिविलज होगा एक मैनेजर को
ज्यादा प्रिविलेज होगा। तो हम ये चीज
देखते हैं। दोनों में डिफरेंस यही है। समझ
में आया? दोनों बहुत डिफरेंट चीजें हैं।
बोथ आर नॉट सेम एग्जैक्टली। ये चीज मैंने
बताई स्टार्टिंग में बताया था। एक बंदे ने
पूछा था। तो दोनों में बहुत डिफरेंस है।
राइट? अब समझ में आया आपको?
प्रिविलशन में हम प्रिविलेज के लिए लुक
आउट कर रहे हैं। लेटरल मोमेंट में हम
प्रिविलज के लिए लुक आउट नहीं कर रहे हैं।
हम बस एक्सेस के लिए लुक आउट कर रहे हैं
कि हमें बस एक लैपटॉप से दूसरा सर्वर
एक्सेस हो जाए। तीसरा मशीन एक्सेस हो जाए।
दैट्स द थिंग। ठीक है?
या। बट प्रिविरा में एक लैपटॉप के अंदर ही
मल्टीपल यूज़र्स हो सकते हैं। हम सब सब पे
ट्राई कर सकते हैं कि किसी से हमें एडमिन
एक्सेस मिल जाए। यह जो चीज़ होती है। चलिए,
अब आ गए हैं हमारे आज के लास्ट अह स्लाइड
पे जो कि एक टास्क है और इसका आंसर आप सभी
को करना है। लेट्स सी हाउ मेनी ऑफ़ यू आर
आंसरिंग करेक्टली। यह मुझे देखना है कि आप
में से कितने लोगों को कितना कुछ समझ में
आ गया। ये एक रियलिस्टिक टास्क है। एक
रियलिस्टिक
आपके लिए सिनेरियो है। ध्यान दीजिएगा एंड
तब आप इसको आंसर कीजिएगा। ठीक है?
आप एक एसओसी लेवल वन के एनालिस्ट हैं। एक
जूनियर सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट आप हैं
ऑलरेडी। मान लीजिए यहां तक बन चुके हैं।
ठीक है? सभी लोग रेडी है ना इस टास्क के
लिए?
एवरीवन रेडी फॉर दिस टास्क? लेट मी नो।
एसओसी की इंटर्नशिप मिल रही है तो ले लो,
भाई, ले लो। अगर इंटरेस्ट है एसओसी में तो
बिल्कुल लो।
ओके। सपोज़ यू सी दिस सीक्वेंस इन लॉग्स।
अगर आप एक एसओसी एल1 हैं तो आप log्स तो
देखेंगे ऑब्वियस सी बात है। तो आपको log
में ये सीक्वेंस देखने को मिलता है जो
यहां पे मैंने सीक्वेंस दे रखा है। क्या
सीक्वेंस है? पहला सीक्वेंस में पहला है
यूजर लैपटॉप एग्जीक्यूट्स मिमिक्स।
यूजर का लैपटॉप मिमीड को एग्जीक्यूट करता
है। एलsस मेमोरी एक्सेस एलsस मेमोरी को
एक्सेस किया जाता है। एडमिन लॉग इन अकर्स
फ्रॉम दैट मशीन। एडमिन का लॉगिन होता है
उस मशीन से। आरडीबी कनेक्शन बनाई जाती है
फाइल सर्वर से। तो व्हिच स्टेजेस अकरर्ड
हियर ट्राई टू आइडेंटिफाई प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन एंड लैटरल मूवमेंट। तो यहां पे
कौन सी स्टेजेस यहां पे अकर हुई हैं?
प्रिविलेज एक्सलेशन या लेटरल मूवमेंट या
दोनों या कोई सी भी नहीं। कौन सी स्टेज
यहां पे हुई हैं और किस
मतलब कब-कब कौन सी स्टेजेस यहां पे अकर
हुई हैं यह आपको बताना है। वन नंबर, टू
नंबर, थ्री नंबर, फोर नंबर। ऐसे नंबरिंग
कीजिए चैट में आप एंड बताइए। या तो ओवरऑल
बताइए। अगर आपको लगता है कि ओवरऑल
प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन हो रहा है या लेटरल
मूवमेंट हो रहा है, वह बताइए। तो जो भी
जिसका आंसर है आपको 2 मिनट का मैक्सिमम
टाइम मिल रहा है। 2 मिनट में सभी के आंसर
आने चाहिए। यहां पे 80 पीपल आर प्रेजेंट
80 लोग हैं। मुझे 80 चैट्स में लोगों के
आंसर दिखने चाहिए। भले आपका सही हो या गलत
डजंट मैटर। मैं आपको इसका आंसर भी
बताऊंगा, समझाऊंगा भी। बट स्टिल आई वांट
कि सी कि जब ऐसे आपको सिनेरियो दे दिया
जाएगा किसी इंटरव्यू में पूछ दिया जाएगा।
कहीं सामने आपको दिखा दिया जाएगा और आपसे
बोला जाएगा तो आप क्या करेंगे उस केस में?
यह आज की ही क्लास की टास्क है। एक तरह
से। आज की ही क्लास का एक इंटरव्यू
क्वेश्चन है। मान के चलिए। अब बताइए मुझे
इसका आंसर सभी लोग।
आई एम सीइंग द आंसर ऑफ एवरीबॉडी। प्लीज
स्टार्ट आंसरिंग कि 1 2 3 फोर स्टेप्स।
चार स्टेप्स हैं यहां पे। तो चारों पे
प्रिविल एस्केलेशन हो रहा है या लेटरल
मूवमेंट हो रही है या दोनों हो रहा है? या
अलग-अलग एक नंबर पे कुछ और, दो नंबर पे
कुछ और, तीन पे कुछ और, चार पे कुछ और?
कैसे हो रहा है? नंबरिंग करके भी आप बता
सकते हैं। जैसे आपको चाहिए जो आपको समझ
में आ रहा है बताइए।
हम ठीक है
यहां पे कुछ लोग बोल रहे हैं कि
प्रिविलशन प्रिविलेज
प्रिविल एक्सलेशन वन टू थ्री एंड लैटरल
मूवमेंट फोर पे। ठीक है? कुछ लोगों ने ये
बोला है।
ठीक है? अब चलिए मैं आपको यहां पे आप लोग
आंसर करते रहिए। मैं आपको कुछ क्वेश्चन
कुछ आंसर्स बताता हूं जो यहां पे कई लोग
दे रहे हैं यहां पे। कुछ लोग बोल रहे हैं
इनिशियल कॉम्प्रोमाइज फिर क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग देन प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन देन लेटरल
मूवमेंट बहुत अच्छी बात है अ एमएस हुसैन
ठीक है यहां पे निशा चौधरी ने बोला है
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन एंड लेटरल मूवमेंट
ठीक है
वन टू थ्री पे प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन एंड
लेटरल मूवमेंट फोर पे
ओके बोथ सर बोथ हो रहा है बहुत अच्छी बात
है बिल्कुल सही प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन ठीक
है लैटरल मूवमेंट कुछ लोग लैटरल मूवमेंट
बोल रहे हैं। कुछ लोग प्रिविलेज एस्क्लेशन
बोल रहे हैं। ओनली
फर्स्ट पे एग्जीक्यूट मिड्स क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग एक्सेस एल्स एक्सट्रैक्ट पासवर्ड्स
यास। ठीक है? एडमिन लॉग इन प्रिविलेज
एक्सक्लेशन आरडीपी टू फाइल सर्वर लेटरल
मूवमेंट बहुत अच्छी बात है। फोर स्कल वन
पे बोथ टू पे बोथ थ्री पे प्रिविलेज चार
पे लेटरल। ओके ठीक है।
टू पे प्रिज सॉरी टू पे प्रिविलेज।
हसनबर्ग अच्छा ठीक है।
चलिए बोथ हो रहा है। चलिए यहां पर कई
लोगों ने आंसर दिया है एंड कुछ लोगों ने
मैक्सिमम बहुत सारे लोगों ने बोला है तो
बोथ प्रिविलज्लेशन एंड लैटरल मूवमेंट। कुछ
लोगों ने बोला है प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन कुछ
लोगों ने लैटरल मूवमेंट बोला है। तो जिन
लोगों ने सिंगल आंसर करा है यहां पे दोज़
हु हैव आंसर्ड सिंगल कि प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन हुआ है या सिर्फ लैटरल मूवमेंट
हुआ है। तो उनका आंसर तो गलत है यहां पे।
क्योंकि सिर्फ एक नहीं हुआ है। प्रिविल
एस्केलेशन या तो सिर्फ प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन
नहीं हुआ है या तो लैटरल मूवमेंट सिर्फ
नहीं हुआ है। दोनों ही हुए हैं। प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन भी हुए हैं एंड लैटरल मूवमेंट
भी हुआ है। बोथ ऑफ दीज़ हैड हैपन। अब ये
कैसे हुआ है? तो मैं आपको बताता हूं। पहले
फर्स्ट स्टेप पे यूजर लैपटॉप एग्जीक्यूट्स
मिमीज। mmc को एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है।
तो मिमीज का यूज़ किस लिए किया जाता है?
मैं आपको यहां पे याद दिलाना चाहता हूं
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग में। क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग में। तो ये पार्ट ये किसके टेक्निक
है? ये है प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन के ही
टेक्निक। दिस इज़ द प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
टेक्निक। बट यहां पे प्रिविलेज एस्केलेट
नहीं हो रही है। टेक्निक का यूज़ किया जा
रहा है। किस चीज़ के लिए? क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग के लिए। तो इट विल बी बेटर इन द
इंटरव्यू इफ यू विल से कि हियर वी आर
सीइंग द क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग।
उसके बाद एल्स मेमोरी एक्सेस किया जाता
है। यहां पर भी क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग हो रही
है क्योंकि एल्स की मेमोरी एक्सेस की जा
रही है। उसके बाद एडमिन लॉगिन हो रहा है।
एडमिन लॉग इन तो तभी होगा ना जब आपने
क्रेडेंशियल डंप करके और ऑलरेडी प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन अब चालू किया है। तो यहां पे
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन आपका परफॉर्म हो रहा
है। एंड देन आरडीपी कनेक्शन बन रही है
फाइल सर्वर से। यानी कि एक आपने क्या
किया? न सिस्टम से फाइल सर्वर में आप घुस
रहे हैं। यानी कि एक एक डिवाइस से दूसरे
डिवाइस में जा रहे हैं। तो यहां पे आपका
क्या हो रहा है? यहां पे आपका लैटरल
मूवमेंट हो रहा है। तो बेसिकली दिस इज़ हाउ
यू हैव टू अंडरस्टैंड दिस कि पहले
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग यहां पे हो रही है।
प्रिविल एस्केलेशन हुआ है। एंड देन आपका
जो है वो क्या हो रहा है लास्ट में? लैटरल
मूवमेंट हो रहा है। सो दिस इज़ द मेन थिंग।
ठीक है?
गॉट इट? यह आपको समझ में आ गया। हालांकि
जो एलसेस मेमोरी एक्सेसिंग एंड मेमिकैडज
का यूज़ है, यह प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन के ही
टेक्निक्स हैं। ठीक है? मैं आपको पहले ही
बता रहा था। आपको पहले भी बताया था
प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन के टेक्निक्स हैं। तो
इट विल कम अंडर प्रिविलज एस्केलेशन। बट
यहां पे हो क्या रहा है? क्रेनेंशियल
डंपिंग। तो आप इसको थोड़ा एक्सप्लसिट हो के
बताएंगे। आप थोड़ा सा स्पेसिफिक होके
बताएंगे तो सामने वाले को लगेगा यू हैव द
एक्चुअल नॉलेज कि मिमीट्स का यूज़ कहां पे
किया जाता है। क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग में
किया जाता है। तो उसको वो चीज़ समझ में
आएगी। राइट? तो उसको लगेगा हां आपको
प्रॉपर टेक्निकल नॉलेज है। तभी आप इतना
तोड़मोड़ के बता रहे हो। अदरवाइज सीधा बोलते
हैं कि ये ये ऐसे-से राइट? तो बस ये चीज
आपको समझनी है थोड़ी सी। जब इंटरव्यू पर्पस
से आप कहीं पे जा रहे हैं तो इंटरव्यू जब
आप दे रहे हैं तो आपके जैसे हजारों लोग
इंटरव्यू के लाइन में लगे होते हैं। एंड
उसमें आपको क्रैक करना होता है। अपनी एक
एबिलिटी दिखानी पड़ती है। अपना एक
एनालिटिकल एबिलिटी एनालिटिक्स थोड़ा सा
माइंड का जो है ना वो दिखाना होता है कि
कितने आप शार्प माइंड से आप चीजों को टैकल
कर रहे हैं। कितना एफिशिएंटली टैकल कर रहे
हैं। तभी तो आपको हायर करेंगे। नहीं तो
फिर आपके जैसे तो वहां पे बहुत सारे लोग
हैं। राइट? तो ये आपका आंसर है। तो आंसर
क्या है यहां पे? सिंपल सा फंडा है
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग या आप ऐसे बोल सकते
हैं कि पहले आपका प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन हो
रहा है। अगर मैं सिर्फ ये दो के लिए पूछूं
एंड देन आपका लैटरल मूवमेंट हो रहा है।
प्रिविलशन एंड लैटरल मूवमेंट दोनों चीजें
हो रही हैं। फर्स्ट तीन पे आप ये जो
फर्स्ट तीन पे आप प्रिविल एस्केलेशन बोल
सकते हैं। एंड लास्ट वाले पे जो है आप
लेटरल मूवमेंट बोल सकते हैं। अगर सिर्फ दो
पूछा जाए। बट अगर ज्यादा टेक्निकल आंसर
करना है आपको तो आप बताएंगे कि फर्स्ट एंड
सेकंड पे क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग हो रही है।
थर्ड पे प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन कंप्लीट हो
रहा है। एंड फोर्थ पे आपका जो है वो लैटरल
मूवमेंट जो है वो हो रही है। आई थिंक आपको
समझ में आ गया होगा।
बिल्कुल सही है। सही है। सही है। सही है।
आपका आंसर सही है। रवि रवि रंजन जी आपका
आंसर बिल्कुल सही है। बट मैंने जैसा कि
बोला मोर टेक्न के लिए थोड़ा सा टेक्निकल
उसके लिए आप इसे बोल सकते हैं। राइट? गॉट
इट? अगर इन दोनों में से बताना हो सिर्फ
तो मैंने बता ही दिया। अगर दोनों में से
सिर्फ बताना हो तो प्रिविलज्लेशन फर्स्ट
थ्री में और लास्ट वाले में लैटरल
मूवमेंट।
गॉट इट?
यह आपको आंसर यहां पे भी मैंने यहां पे
लिख दिया आपके लिए कि मिमीज एग्जीक्यूट
हुई है तो क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग हुई है।
एल्स एक्सेस हुआ है तो क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग
हुई है। एडमिन लॉग इन हुआ है तो प्रिविलज
एस्केलेशन हुआ है। आरडीपी से फाइल सब में
मूव किया है तो लेटरल मूवमेंट हुआ है। तो
बेसिकली क्या हो रहा है? क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग, प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन एंड लेटरल
मूवमेंट। क्योंकि क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन का ही पार्ट है,
टेक्निक है। तो, आप सिर्फ यह दोनों भी
कंसीडर कर सकते हैं। अगर आपसे पूछा जाए कि
सिर्फ दो ही बताइए दोनों में से कौन सा
हुआ है या कैसे हुआ है? तो प्रिविलज
एक्सेलेशन लैटरल मूवमेंट अगर दो ही पूछ
रहा है। अगर कोई ऐसा रिक्वायरमेंट है, ऐसा
कोई कंडीशन नहीं है कि दो ही बताना है, तो
आप पूरी डिटेल में बताइए इंटरव्यूअर को।
वो खुश हो जाएगा आपसे। आपको शाबाशियां
देगा और आपको हायर भी करेगा। ठीक है? समझ
में आ गया?
इतना तो समझ में आ गया वो? क्लियर तो हो
गया कि नहीं हुआ? हूं अभी भी बताओ यार
बताओ भाई बताओ बताओ ओके शाबासिया लेकिन
शाबासिया अरे भाई लाइक नहीं ठोका क्या आज
तुम लोगों ने अच्छा लाइक थोड़े कम ठोके
हैं लोगों ने कोई बात नहीं ठोक देना
जाते-जाते ठोक देना
यस सेलर आपका आंसर सही था
ऑल क्लियर
लॉक कर दिया जाए चलिए ठीक है सो दैट्स
व्हाट फॉर टुडेेस सेशन आज के लिए इतना था
आपके लिए।
हां, इंटरव्यूअर बेसिक नॉलेज बहुत ज्यादा
पूछते हैं। बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स पे बहुत
ज्यादा फोकस करते हैं एंड बहुत ज्यादा
फोकस करते हैं बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स पे। तो,
यह बात याद रखिएगा।
यहां पे किसी ने सुपर चैट किया था। मैंने
उस टाइम ध्यान नहीं दिया है। एक्स
क्या नाम है? एक्सप्ल एक्सप्लोसिव ओ। भाई
सुपर चैट करो या आते हो तो कम से कम नाम
ऐसा रखो कि बोल पाए इंसान। गिव टू एग्जाम।
आई वाज़ नॉट एबल टू अटेंड सीरीज। कैन आई
स्टार्ट नाउ? बिल्कुल आप स्टार्ट कर सकते
हैं एक्सप्लोजी बट वन टू न तक का वन टू 10
तक का पहले देख लीजिए फिर 11th में लाइव
में आप आ जाइएगा। ठीक है
थैंक्स फॉर स्पेंडिंग योर वैल्यूुएबल टाइम
टू टीच अस डिफरेंस। थैंक यू वेरी मच
विष्णु। आई होप कि आपको ऐसे ही नॉलेज और
स्किल्स आप अपने बढ़ाते नॉलेज लेते रहिए।
एंड मैं तो अवेलेबल हूं ही। मैं तो ऑलवेज
अवेलेबल रहूंगा आप लोगों के लिए। तो इसके
लिए कोई टेंशन नहीं लेनी है। तो आज के
सेशन के लिए इतना ही रखते हैं। इतना ही
करते हैं। एंड आई होप कि आपको अच्छे से
समझ में भी आया होगा। आपने कुछ गेन करा
है। एंड अगर इंफॉर्मेशन लगी हो सेशन तो बस
दैट्स इट। मैं वही बोलूंगा कि वीडियो को
उन सबके बीच शेयर कीजिए जो आपके दोस्त जो
आपके कोलीग्स हैं जो एसओसी एनालिस्ट बनना
चाहते हैं। एसओसी एल1 बनना चाहते हैं एंड
इस फील्ड में जाना चाहते हैं। एक जॉब रेडी
ट्रेनिंग फ्री में करना चाहते हैं। पैसों
की किसी को दिक्कत है। कोई अ साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में करियर नहीं बना पा रहा है।
करियर साइबर सिक्योरिटी में घुस नहीं पा
रहा है। एंट्री नहीं ले पा रहा है क्योंकि
उसके पास महंगे सर्टिफिकेशंस नहीं है।
पैसे ज्यादा नहीं है। अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकता
ट्रेनिंग कोर्सर्सेस महंगे-महंगे और एसओसी
के थ्रू जाना चाहता है तो उसके लिए यह आप
रिकमेंड कर सकते हैं। एसओसी लेवल वन की ये
कंप्लीट जॉब रेडी फ्री ट्रेनिंग विद
क्वालिटी जो कि डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के साइड से
आपको मैं डिलीवर कर रहा हूं। एंड आई होप
कि आप उन तक यह स्प्रेड करेंगे। अगर अच्छा
लगता है तो लाइक ठोकते चले जाइएगा एंड
शेयर करते रहिएगा। दैट्स इट। मैं यही
बोलूंगा। ग्रुप को ज्वाइन कर लीजिएगा।
चैनल को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। ये गिव अवे आ
रहा है बहुत जल्द। जिन्होंने भी शेयर करा
था पहले अभी तक हमारी इस वीडियोस को उनके
लिए जीतने का मौका मिलेगा उनको वाउचर्स
वगैरह तो वहां पे जरूर जॉइ कर लीजिएगा।
दैट्स इट गाइस टुडे फॉर टुडेेस एंड मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में। ठीक है?
ओके। नेक्स्ट क्लास से मिलने से पहले टॉप
फैंस वाली लिस्ट तो हमने देखी नहीं। टॉप
फैंस वाली देख लेते हैं भाई। ये बार
कभी-कभी भूल जाता हूं मैं। सो लेट्स सी
टॉप फैंस।
तो टॉप फैंस में यहां पर हमारे भैया लोग
रिक्वेद पॉल ऋषु मिस्टर जट टॉप आदित्य
इट्स इट्स हलीन ओके नमन ठाकुर फाइनेंस कॉम
ललित मोहन दास खालिद प्रशांत तनेजा आकाश
मास्टर गेमिंग आदित्य गौरव अल्टीमेट
गेमिंग जेडी कोडर गर्ल्स थिंक विदु शेखर
विष्णु अह कांधे कौन
अरे भाई नाम यार ऐसा रखते हैं। ठीक है।
शिवानी अ मिथुन शुभम इट्स एसटी हैकर निशा
चौधरी रोहित हसनबर्ग कोड एरर रवि रवि रंजन
मिस्टर रोबो रबरदा ठीक है अश्विन फॉर स्कल
आयुष पटेल पीतांबर रैंडम बॉय नवल रूट
एक्सप्लइट सुदामा ओके सूरज ओके कई कई सारे
नाम है अमित यादव जगतगुरु स्वामी एंड
साहित्य एंड प्रदीप एंड सरविल ठीक है द
डायरी एंड शैलेश कुमार। ठीक है? ओके। थैंक
यू गाइस। थैंक यू सो मच फॉर बीइंग हियर।
थैंक यू सो मच फॉर बीइंग इन द टॉप फैंस
लिस्ट। क्योंकि आप लोग के वजह से काफी
यहां पे इंगेजमेंट रहती है। काफी अच्छा
लगता है। जितने भी लोग यहां पे प्रेजेंट
होते हैं अटेंड करते हैं। आई एम रियली
ग्लैड यू आर हियर गाइस। तो थैंक यू सो मच।
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में मजे से। एक
और इंटरेस्टिंग क्लास के साथ, इंटरेस्टिंग
टॉपिक के साथ। एंड देन जो है आपका
अनाउंसमेंट आ जाएगा जल्दी ही फटाफट जब भी
नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी बस आप एक काम कर
दीजिएगा 200 प्लस कमेंट्स कंप्लीट जितनी
जल्दी चाहे कोशिश कीजिएगा हो जाए एंड आई
विल ब्रिंगिंग द नेक्स्ट क्लास सो प्लीज
200 कमेंट्स थोड़ा जल्दी कीजिएगा 200
कमेंट्स ठीक है बहुत लेट आप करते हैं करना
तो होता ही है तो जल्दी कर दिया कीजिए तो
आपका ही भला है ठीक है ओके बाय गाइस थैंक
यू फॉर जॉइनिंग एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
सेशन में सभी को शुभ रात्रि नमस्ते एंड
टाटा